MEETING TO ORDER.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM THAT WE
WILL PROCEED AS SUBCOMMITTEE.
SARAH Y. CASKET [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERITS.
CG ARE THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
S. P. SIXTY FOUR IS TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S INCREASE
PENETRATION OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
AYE DOES NOT LEAD TO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF INCREASED AIR
POLLUTION.
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA ALREADY
BURKE BREATHED SOME OF THE
UNHEALTHY ASTAIRE AND NATION
THIS PROTECTION WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THE AIR QUALITY DOES NOT
GET ANY WORSE.
SO HERE'S THE PROBLEM WE HAVE
OUR POOR AIR QUALITY CALIFORNIA
HAS SOME OF THE MOST POLLUTED
AIR IN THE COUNTRY COMMUNITIES
IN AREAS THROUGHOUT THE NORTH
THE CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
EXPERIENCE MANY DAYS WHEN AIR
QUALITY THIS NOT MEET --
PROTECTIVE STANDARDS.
THE OPERATION OF ONE POWER PLANT
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY IN.
PACKED THE QUALITY OF THE AIR
ENOUGH IN ANY LOCALITY EACH TURN
OF POLLUTION CONCRETE AT FIRST.
CONSEQUENCES IN MANY AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOT MEETING
PROTECTIVE AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
AND MODELING SHOWS THAT THE
SINGLE POWER PLANT CAN NEARLY
DOUBLE THE CONCENTRATIONS OF
POLLUTANTS.
ARM FROM BACKGROUND LEVELS SO
CHANGING OPERATIONS THE POWER
PLANTS IS LIKELY TO MAKE YOUR
CALL THE WORSE IF IF WE DON'T
CONSIDER AND MAKE CERTAIN
CONSIDERATIONS.
LIKE HILL POWER PLANTS ARE
LIKELY TO BE CYCLE MORE OFTEN
MANY THE STATE'S NATURAL GAS
POWER PLANTS ARE CONSTRUCTED TO
PROVIDE BASED POWER OR POWER
ONLY DURING RARE PEAK NEEDS.
THIS IS CHANGING AS CALIFORNIA
BRINGS MORE RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
TO THE THE GREAT ESPECIALLY
SOLAR ENERGY NATURAL GAS UNITS
ARE INCREASINGLY BEING RAMP DOWN
OR TURNED OFF IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE DAY.
THEN RAMP BACK UP OR A A TERM
PACKED ON TO MEET IN A EVENING
ELECTRICITY.
CYCLING PRODUCES MORE EMISSIONS.
SO CYCLING NATURAL GAS PLANTS BY
STARTING STOPPING AN OPERATING
AT PARTIAL LOADS PRODUCES
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE AIR POLLUTION
THAN FACILITIES OPERATING IT
BASELITZ.
POLLUTION MAY INCREASE IF THIS
IS NOT ADDRESS SO THIS INCREASE
IN THE CYCLING HAS ALREADY
STARTED CURRENT STUDY SUGGESTS
THAT THIS ISSUE --
WILL ONLY BECOME MORE ACUTE
THOSE STUDIES CONDUCTED BY THE
ART OF PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND IN THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING A PROCEEDING
IN BY THE THE CAL ISIS SUGGESTED
IN THE CERTAIN SCENARIOS.
KNOCKS POLLUTION ASSOCIATED WITH
NATURAL GAS GENERATION GAS
GENERATION OF BOTH IN PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES IN IN THE STATE IS A
WHOLE WILL INCREASE AS STATE
MEET SAYS --
NATURAL GAS OUT REQUIREMENTS AND
INCREASE RENEWABLE REQUIREMENTS
SO THIS BILL REQUIRES A
ACCESSIBLE DATA RELATED TO POWER
PLANTS A OPERATION.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE INCREASED
DATA AVAILABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY RELATED TO POWER
PLANT OPERATIONS INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY AND DATA USABLE
DATA THAT'S A RELATED TO HELP
POWER PLANTS ARE OPERATING
[inaudible]
FULLER DISTRICT CEDAR CHANGING
OPERATIONS AND PERMITS THE BILL
OF NEXT REQUIRED TO THEIR
DISTRICTS ANALYZE HOW POWER
PLANTS ARE ACTUALLY OPERATING
AND LIKELY TO OPERATE IN THE
FUTURE CHEN SURE.
AT THAT PROTECTIONS ARE INCLUDED
IN APPLICABLE PERMITS MANY THESE
PERMITS ARE.
YEARS OLD AND THEY WERE THERE'S
AN ASSUMPTION THAT THE COULD BE
OPERATING ALL THE TIME AND
FINALLY IT REQUIRES A STUDY ON
HEALTH.
HOW TO PHASE OUT NATURAL GAS
PLANTS YOU KNOW THE BILL
REQUIRES A STEADY AND HOW TO
PRIORITIZE TO REDUCTION OF THE
USAGE AND EVENTUAL RETIREMENT OF
NATURAL GAS?
OF FACILITIES MOST IMPACTING THE
AIR QUALITY OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES ARE
BREATHING AND HEALTHIER.
NOW THE OPPOSITION HAS FOCUSED
ON TWO PRIMARY ARGUMENTS FIRST
THE POWER PLANT EMISSIONS ARE
SMALL WITH ANOTHER SECTORS AND
SHOULD NOT BE THE FOCUS.
INTO THAT THIS BILL IMPACTS
RELIABILITY A CONTRARY.
I'M ONE POWER ONCE POWER PLANTS
EMISSIONS CAN SIGNIFICANTLY.
SIMPLIFICATION THE IMPACT LOCAL
AIR QUALITY ANY SUGGESTION THAT
MINIMIZING POWER PLANT EMISSIONS
SHOULD NOT BE PRIORITIZE A CALL.
IGNORES THE YEAR IMPACTS ON
COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE NEXT TO IN
THE ARE NATURAL.
GAS POWER PLANTS FOR EXAMPLE IN
ITS ANALYSIS OF THE PICKUP
APPEAL PEAK OF FACILITY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
FOUND THAT EMISSIONS FROM THE
PICO PEAK.
PO PICO FACILITY COULD NEARLY
DOUBLE OF THE ONE HOUR
CONCENTRATION OF NIGHT AND THAT
SHE KNOCKS IT RIGHT FROM.
BACKGROUND LEVELS THE ANALYSIS
ALSO FOUND THAT APPEAL PICO
FACILITY COULD CONTRIBUTE TO THE
AREAS NOT A TEAM IN A FEDERAL
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS FOR BOTH
FINE AND COARSE A PARTICULAR
BOTTOM MATTER.
CONTRARY TO THE OPPOSITION'S US
STATEMENT THAT THIS BILL WILL
HURT RELIABILITY BILL EXPLICITLY
ENSURES THAT RELIABILITY IS
PROTECTED.
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY DURATION OF POWER
PLANTS IN THE CURRENT LAW BUT
THERE IS NOT A MECHANISM TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL RELIABILITY IS
PROTECTED THIS BILL PROVIDES
THAT PROTECTION.
BY REQUIRING COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN HERE DISTRICT AND THE
BALANCING AT THIRTY AUTHORITY
DAY AHEAD RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
ESTIMATED TO PROVIDE 98% OF THE
I. SO'S ENERGY NEEDS THIS BILL
REQUIRES SENATOR DISTRICT
NOTIFIED THE BALANCING
AUTHORITY.
AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS IN
ADVANCE OF THE BAD AIR QUALITY
DAY TO ENSURE THAT IT CAN MEET
RELIABILITY REQUIREMENTS IN THE
NEXT DAY MARK.
WITH ME.
A COUPLE OF EXPERTS THAT WILL.
SHARE WITH YOU THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THE BETTER.
AND I URGE AND I'VE.
BEFORE PROCEEDING FURTHER
SENATOR --
YOU.
AWAY EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AND
OF THAT COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING MY AMENDMENTS
[inaudible] FOR ALRIGHT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
AND THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS SEAN ALLOWS ZERO I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
--
SAT HOW THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
IS.
A AND GROUP THAT FOCUSES ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE HAVE MEMBERS FROM
THE SAN DIEGO BORDER ON
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH COALITION.
AND WE HAVE MEMBERS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
THE BAY AREA ON THE CENTRAL
COAST.
AND AND WE HAVE WORKED ON AIR
QUALITY AND ENERGY ISSUES FOR
MANY YEARS ON AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S TRULY
NECESSARY AT THIS TIME BECAUSE
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE BREATHING
SOME OF THE MOST UNHEALTHY.
AIR IN THE ENTIRE NATION --
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY CALIFORNIA
HAS EIGHT OF THE TOP TEN WORST
CITY. TO KILL A MATTER POLLUTION
[inaudible]
ON AND ONE SINGLE POWER PLANTS
EMISSIONS CAN MAKE THAT
POLLUTION NOTABLY WORSE.
AND THE EXAMPLE THAT I WOULD
OFFER -- TO
THIS COMMITTEE AT THE CONCRETE
EXAMPLE IS THAT PINOCHET ENERGY
CENTER WHICH IS LOCATED IN THE
TOP FIVE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY.
I'M IN FRESNO COUNTY.
AT THAT FACILITY I'M HAD
SIGNIFICANT MODELING DONE NOT
WHEN IT WAS FIRST PERMITTED BY
THE AIR DISTRICT --
AND ABOUT MODELING SHOWED THAT
IT WOULD --
RESULTS IN VIOLATIONS OF BOTH
THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR PARTICULATE
MATTER STANDARD AND THE ANNUAL
STANDARD ON IT WOULD RESULT IN
--
I EXCEEDED HIS OF OVER A OF A
100%.
THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR STANDARD SO
THE CONTENTION THAT POWER PLANTS
ARE NOT A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
THE PROBLEM AND IS BELIEVED BY
THAT MODELING FOR THAT
PARTICULAR PLANT THAT MODELING
ONLY LOOKED AT STEADY STATE
OPERATIONS IT DID NOT.
LOOKED AT START UPS IN
PARTICULAR AND THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE PINOCHET IS
IN FACT STARTING AND STOPPING
NEARLY EVERYDAY.
LAST YEAR EACH OF ITS FOUR UNITS
STARTED OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TIMES. ONE OF THE UNITS OF
THE PANACHE PLANT HAD AND KNOCKS
RATE OF ONE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
POUNDS PER AND THE T. YOU.
WHEN IT STARTS?
BUT ITS STEADY STATE EMISSIONS
ARE EIGHT POUNDS.
PER AND BTO.
GOOD I'M IN THIS MEANS I'M SORRY
ETCETERA SO THE START UP
EMISSIONS FOR THAT PARTICULAR
PLANT ARE TEN TIMES MORE THAN
THE STEADY STATE EMISSIONS.
AND THIS IS REPLICATED IN OTHER
PLANTS AROUND THE STATE BUT THE
STATE'S WERE NOT GENERALLY
PERMITTED AS AS TO REFLECT THOSE
VARIATIONS IN OPERATION.
SO TO ADDRESS THIS THE BILL
PROPOSED TO DO THREE THINGS --
IT REQUIRES DATA AND
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW THESE
PLANTS ARE OPERATING.
SECOND IT REQUIRES THE AIR
DISTRICTS TO LOOK AT THE IMPACT
THAT THE PLANTS ARE HAVING AND
TO CONDUCT ITS REGULAR --
ANNUAL PERMIT REVIEWS TO REFLECT
THE IMPACTS THE PLANTS ARE
HAVING AND TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE BOUNCING AUTHORITY IN DOING
SO.
AND THEN FINALLY IT REQUIRES THE
STUDY THINK TANK.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND OR
WHISTLIN ON THE SENIOR MANAGER
WITH THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS OUT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON GRID MANAGEMENT
ISSUES IN CONTINUING TO DO
RESEARCH UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR
GREAT LOOKS LIKE IN THE FUTURE
AS WE BRING ON MORE.
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND MEET OUR
CLIMATE TARGETS I'M GONNA CUT MY
TESTIMONY IN HALF AT LEAST
BECAUSE I THINK SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI IN CHINA DID A REALLY
COMPELLING JOB TALKING ABOUT
WHAT THE BILL DAVID WHAT THE
BILL.
DOES IN THE PROBLEM IT'S TRYING
TO ACHIEVE OUT TO SAY THAT
NATURAL GAS CURRENTLY SUPPLIES
ABOUT 40% OF OUR ELECTRICITY
NEEDS AND WILL CONTINUE TO PLAY
A ROLE HONOR SYSTEM. FOR
SOMETIME AND I'M SAYING THIS
BECAUSE I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT THE PURPOSE OF SB SIXTY
FOUR IS NOT TO INDISCRIMINATELY
SHUT DOWN NATURAL GAS.
RATHER THE BILL IS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE HAPPEN AND WE
THINK IT'S GOING TO GET A LOT
WORSE OVER TIME AND THAT'S THE
MUCH MORE FREQUENT INCREASE IN
CYCLING OF THE GAS UNITS.
AND THE POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE
IMPACT THAT THIS CAN HAVE ON AIR
QUALITY ESPECIALES IN AREAS THAT
SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO GET
THEIR AIR ANY DIRTIER
[inaudible]
SO.
LIKE CHINA SAID BEFORE THE
PROBLEM IS THAT MANY OF THE
STATE'S PLANTS WERE BUILT TO
PROVIDE BASELOAD STEADY STATE
POWER NOT EXPECTED TO BE TURNED
ON AND OFF ON A DAILY BASIS.
AND AS A RESULT THIS MORE
FREQUENT CYCLING WAS NOT
ANTICIPATED AND THEIR AIR
PERMITS THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIANS ARE
ALREADY STARTING TO FEEL THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
COMMITTEES IN THE STATE READ
SOME OF THE UNHEALTHY IS AIR IN
THE COUNTRY. FOR THESE REASONS
WE BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THE STATE SHIFT TO CLEANER NON
FOSSIL RESOURCES AT THE SAME
TIME THE STATE DOES NEED BETTER
TOOLS TO UNDERSTAND HOW CHANGING
NATURAL GAS PLANT OPERATIONS.
MAY IMPACT AIR QUALITY AN
EXPLICIT MECHANISM FOR AIR
DISTRICTS TO COORDINATE WITH
GRID OPERATORS TO REDUCE THE
DISPATCH OF NATURAL GAS PLANTS
ON THE WORST AIR QUALITY DAYS.
SB SIXTY FOUR WOULD ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S RAMP UP IN CLEAN
GENERATION DOES NOT LEAD TO THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
FREQUENTLY CYCLING GAS POWER
PLANTS.
IN A WAY THAT INCREASES AIR
POLLUTION.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN WHITE
THE QUEEN PARA CAMP WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING AND OF US GETS
WITH.
THE CALIFORNIA ARMS JUST
ALLIANCE BUT ALSO WITH ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTS AND I WORK
AS WELL FOR LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUST ACCOUNTABILITY.
IF YOU ARE CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ALSO HERE IN BEHALF OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE GOING
FURTHER LIKE --
TO ESTABLISHED QUORUM
[inaudible]
AND SECONDLY ON THE RIGHT.
MEMBERS ROUTE TO TRIGGER
RUPTURED HERE ACOSTA HERE ACOSTA
HERE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE FLORA.
FLORA HERE IN LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MELENDEZ BELINDA'S
HERE RAYOS [inaudible]
STONE.
THANK YOU HAVE A QUORUM --
I WOULD LIKE TO NOW INVITE UP.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL
.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LEO SO REFORM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
I CHAMBER OPPOSES SB SIXTY FOUR
BECAUSE IT GRANTS UNFETTERED
AUTHORITY TO LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
TO LIMIT THE OPERATION OF ENERGY
FACILITIES NEEDED TO MEET PEAK
ELECTRICITY DEMAND.
AND ON TOP OF THAT CREATES A
CUMBERSOME PROCESS THAT STOOD I
PUT IT IN SOMETIMES CONTRARY TO
EXISTING LAW AND REGULATIONS.
ALSO THREATENS CALIFORNIA JOBS
BY FORCING ENERGY PROVIDERS TO
GO OUTSIDE OF THE STATE TO ME
POTENTIAL ENERGY DEMANDS.
THE PROPOSED THE BILL POINT TO A
FEAR THAT STARTUP SHUTDOWNS AND
CYCLING ARE NOT CONSIDERED AN
ORIGINAL AIR QUALITY PERMITS AS
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER SMARTY JONES
AND AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTEDOUT.
MANY AGING GAS FIRED POWER
PLANTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
REPLACED RETIRED A REPOWERED
ALSO SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
TECHNOLOGY HAVE INCREASED
EFFICIENCIES OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS AND GAS FIRED
POWER PLANTS.
SUPPORTERS SUGGEST THAT THESE
START UP SHUT DOWN CYCLING'S MAY
ACCOUNT FOR THE MAJORITY OF
INCREASED EMISSIONS FROM THIS
FACILITY HOWEVER THE BILL GOES
ON TO ORDER MORE SHUT DOWN
STARTUP DEPENDING ON NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS.
AND DOES SO WHETHER WHETHER OR
NOT THAT FACILITIES IT OPERATING
WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF ITS
PERMITS.
THE BILL TWENTY FOUR HOUR NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS ARE UNWORKABLE IN
OUR OPINION.
ENERGY FACILITIES DO NOT HAVE AN
ON OFF SWITCH IN MOSCOW THURS
THROUGH CERTAIN STEPS TO SHUT
DOWN SAFELY ALTHOUGH THE BILL
DOES CONTAIN AN EXCEPTION WE
RECOGNIZE THAT FOR CONTINUE
GENERATION DURING PEAK DEMAND.
TIME WHEN ALSO DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE.
A COMPLEX ENERGY GRID DECISIONS
WHICH ARE MADE INCREASINGLY
SHORT INCREMENTS OF TIME HOURS
OR EVEN MINUTES THESE DAYS.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
RIGHTLY POINTS OUT THERE MANY
LAWS IN PLACE ALREADY REGULATED
VERY IMPACTS OUGHT TO BE
ADDRESSED BY THAT BILL. FOR
EXAMPLE THE BILL SEEKS TO LIMIT
LOCAL AIR EMISSIONS THROUGH YET
ANOTHER PERMIT PROCESS BUT THE
AIRPORT AUTHORITY REQUIRED TO
CONTROL EMISSIONS AND COORDINATE
WITH LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS TO
LIMIT STATIONARY SOURCE
EMISSIONS SOUGHT TO BE
CONTROLLED BY THIS BILL.
THE BILL ALSO SEEKS TO TAKE IT
ACTION DURING NON ATTAINMENT
DAVIS BUT THE AIRPORT IS ALREADY
REQUIRED TO PREPARE DETAILED
SATED WITH IMPLEMENTATION PLANS
ON HOW TO ACHIEVE ATTAINMENT.
BOTH THROUGH THE SET AND NOW
UNDER AB SIX SEVENTEEN ACTED
JUST LAST YEAR WHICH REQUIRES A
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS TWO
HOLISTICALLY EXAMINE LOCAL AIR
QUALITY ISSUES IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE BILL ALSO SEEKS TO LIMIT THE
OPERATION OF FOSSIL FUEL
GENERATING UNITS SEEMINGLY IS A
MEANS TO ENCOURAGE ADDITIONAL
RENEWABLE PROCUREMENT.
THE GENERATORS ARE RT A MANDATED
TO UNDERGO A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS AND SUBMITTED DETAILED
PROCUREMENT PLAN.
WITH THE ALREADY LEGISLATOR
REQUIREMENTS TO INCORPORATE
RENEWABLES ENERGY SOURCES AND
MINIMIZE YOUR LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION.
FINALLY AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO
ENACTED LAST YEAR ALREADY ALLOWS
THE AIRPORTS ISSUED ABATEMENT
ORDER WHEN AIR POLLUTANTS
CONSTITUTE AN IMMINENT AND
SUBSTANTIAL ENDANGERMENT FROM A
FACILITY.
ENSURING THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
OUR ENERGY POLICY IS A LAUDABLE
GOAL.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT THE
METHODS PROPOSED BY THIS BILL OR
CONVERT CUMBERSOME FRAUGHT WITH
LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS THAT DON'T
WORK WITH IN THE README REALITY
OF ENERGY RELIABILITY.
AND DOES NOT ACTUALLY HAVE A
HIGH LIKELIHOOD OF EXCEEDING ON
THIS SCHOOL. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN NOVA.
THANK YOU I'M CHANCE BUT HE
JONES WITH THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS --
AND WE REPRESENT BOTH UTILITY
SCALE RENEWABLE COULD A LOOK OF
THE TODAY WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT ARE GHASTLY AND THAT
GASOLINE IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON INTO THAT
MEET RELIABILITY NEEDS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE THIS
FACTOID THAT SOME.
ON ALL THE GAS PLAN.
COMMUTER ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
GOALS -- IT
IS NECESSARY IT IT REALLY ISN'T
THE FACT THAT A MATTER IS --
INCLUDING THE S. B. THREE FIFTY
STUDY WHICH WAS DONE AT THE
BEHEST OF THE LEGISLATURE THE UP
BEFORE THE I SO --
THE COMBINED CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
ABOUT 21% --
OF THE OF THE LOAD AT YOU CAN BE
ANOTHER WHICH IT THE GHASTLY IS
1%.
OF THE COMBINED CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS SO IT IS NOT A AT A
THAT WHEN I SAY ITS NOT
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE THREE PARTS OF THIS BILL ONE
PART A LET'S GET THAT OFF THE
TABLE RIGHT AWAY THE DATA.
THESE THESE PLANTS ARE
CONTINUOUSLY MONITORED TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN TO THE AIR DISTRICTS
HAVE THAT DATA OKAY THE AYE AYE
THE P. A PARTNER THE AIRBOARD --
THAT BASICALLY OF MONITORS THE
CARBON OUTPUT OF THESE PLANTS SO
THE ISSUES DATA AND PEOPLE WANNA
PUT STUFF IN A IN A MORE USABLE
FORM GREAT HAVE AT IT BECAUSE
IT'S THERE --
IN IN THOSE PLANTS OPERATE
WITHIN THEIR PERMITS --
VERY STRINGENT STANDARDS AND ALL
THEY ARE DISTRICTS IN THE IN THE
STATE VERY STRINGENT CO TWO
STANDARDS.
THEY COMPLY WITH ALL THOSE SO
THAT'S THAT'S ISSUE ONE THAT THE
SECOND ISSUE WE TOOK --
THE BILL DOES IN FACT THAT
SECTION E. IN THIS BILL --
BASICALLY STRUCTURE SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS LIKE AN A AND THIS IS
MORE OF AN ENERGY COMMITTEE --
ISSUING MAYBE NOT HERE BUT IN
ESSENCE PUTS THE AIR DISTRICTS
--
IN IN IN IN THEIR ISSUANCE OF
PERMITS WHICH POWER PLANTS
OPERATE FIRST --
RATHER THAN LEAVING THAT TO THE
BALLOT SHEET AUTHORITIES WHICH
IS MORE APPROPRIATE --
SO THAT SECTION IS VERY
PROBLEMATIC IT DOES HAVE SECTION
F. I THINK ITSELF THAT ALLOWS
THE BASIE BALANCING AUTHORITY TO
BASICALLY OVERRIDE THAT INTO I
AND THEY CAN HEAT WAVES WHEN WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO BEAT THE AIR
CONDITIONING LOAD WHICH HAS.
OBVIOUSLY REAL HIGH HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH IT
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS THE
PLANT OPERATORS BUILT THE WAY
THIS ACTUALLY WORKS THEY PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT'S IN THEIR
PERMITS.
SO DAVID POLL THEY ONLY HAVE ONE
START DEBT DAY THAT'S ALL
THEY'RE GOING TO DO SO IF IF THE
EYES SO WHERE THE LADY OF THE P.
OR BANK WHICH IS THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
ABILITY OF TORY PICKS UP THE
PHONE AND SAYS WE NEED YOU TO
RUN.
THEY WILL OKAY IT'S THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO TRY TO GET IN
BETWEEN THE BELGIAN AUTHORITIES
AIR DISTRICT THEIR CRIMINAL --
AND CIVIL LIABILITIES FOR NOT
LISTENING TO THE LOCAL AIRPORT
SO THAT THAT'S THAT'S A PROBLEM
AND SO IT IT EH AND TWO LAST
POINTS ONE I'LL.
ALSO POINT OUT IN THAT IN THIS
IS SOMETHING THE COMMITTEE --
IF THEY WANT TO TAKE A BROADER
VIEW ON THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE SECTION OF THE FINEST --
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
IN THIS BILL WAS DESIGNED FOR
BASICALLY --
DISTRIBUTING CAT A CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS THAT'S WHAT IT'S FOR OF
GAY AND THAT'S THAT'S FINE OF
THOSE WITH THE DID LEGISLATURE
DECIDED IT WANTED TO DO.
BUT IT WASN'T DESIGNED TO PUT
REGULATIONS AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES SO THAT THIS IS A
SOMETHING YOU MAY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT HOW THE THAT IT'S SORT OF
AN EXPANSION.
OF THAT OF THAT DEFINITION IS
BEING USED IN AREAS WHICH I
THINK GOT CREATE SOME LEGAL --
MAGNUSON AND MAY LEAD.
TO FINALLY I THINK THERE'S ONE
LAST ISSUE AND THAT IS --
YOU KNOW THESE POWER PLANTS --
HAVE BASICALLY BEEN BUILT
LARGELY LAST ATTENDED FIFTEEN
YEARS THEY DISPLACE THE OLDER
EISENHOWER OUR AIR A GENERATION
THAT WAS THERE.
THEY'RE VERY EFFICIENT DE MITA
MAY MAY HAVE MOST OF THE
STANDARD CD --
TO AND YOU TELL IT BY BY PUTTING
THESE POWER PLANTS IN THERE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ACTUALLY --
YOU KNOW SHUT DOWN PLANTS LIKE A
HUNTERS POINT --
PORTRAYAL OF SOUTH BAY DOWN
SCADA LOW PLANTS THAT CLEARLY
HAD IMPACT ON ABOUT WHAT I THINK
ALL OF US WOULD AGREE WERE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT POWER PLANTS
THAT ARE OPERATE ELSEWHERE IN
THE STATE MEAN ABLE TO MEET
THOSE LOCAL.
LOCAL --
NEED SO --
THAT LAST PART OF THIS BILL
WHERE YOU DID THERE TRYING TO
DECIDE WHO GETS TO RETIRE.
WILL GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
STATE DOESN'T OWN THOSE
RESOURCES IT IT IT IT IT GETS A
LITTLE OUGHT YOU KNOW THAT BIG
RAISES SOME BIG CONCERNS IN IN
OUR MIND IN TERMS OF HOW THAT
ACTUALLY GONNA WORK --
OTHER THAN THAT WE LIKE YOUR
BILL SENATE SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF SIR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL
SAW CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURED
GOODS AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
I THINK GIVE THE LATENESS OF THE
HOUR I WILL JUST GO WITH THAT
ECHO MY COLLEAGUES.
ARE COMMENTS FROM THE CHAMBER --
AND OPPOSE S. B. SIX FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREAT COOK
RIVERS IN THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
OPPOSITION.
A MAN I APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING
ATTORNEY TO GIVE SUPPORT A A MAN
ON THE OFFICE HERE COULD
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ALICE
KESSLER BEHALF OF CALPINE
CORPORATION IN OPPOSITION.
JERRY MEMBERS ANTHONY SAMPSON ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY IN OPPOSITION.
PATRICK WELCH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
TURN MEMBERS BRUCE MIGNON ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA LARGE
ENERGY CONSUMERS IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE REASONS STATED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ILLITERACY FOR THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
ALSO NOT.
MET CLUB SCENE ON BEHALF OF*
BOAST.
ISRAEL SALAS APOLOGIZE FOR
GETTING A LETTER IN LATE WITH
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC ALSO
PUTS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
I UNDER FOR THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI SO NICE TO
SEE YOU AGAIN.
SO IF I PLEDGE IT IS A PLEASURE
SERVING WITH YOU IN THE ASSEMBLY
--
OKAY SO.
YOU HAVE A BILL THAT --
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS TO SHUT DOWN SOME
OF THESE PLANTS AND I'M JUST
KIND OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW IS THAT DETERMINED?
WELL ACTUALLY WON'T BE THE END.
THE VISION IS IT WON'T BE THE
AIR QUALITY DISTRICTS THAT WILL
SHUT IT DOWN BILL.
THEY WILL MAKE THE RECOMMENDED
IT MAKE THE STATEMENT THAT IT'S
A NON ATTAINMENT AIR DAY SO THAT
THERE'S A DESIRABILITY WITH THE
BALANCING AUTHORITY TEMPERING
ONLINE.
OTHER UNITS THAT ARE OUTSIDE
THAT ATTAINMENT AREA SO THERE'S
ALL THESE.
NATURAL GAS PLANTS IN.
JUST LET ME A JONES WAS CRACKED
I'M NOT OPPOSED AND NOT THIS
BILL IS NOT DESIGNED TO SHUT
DOWN ALL THE NATURAL GAS PLANTS
BECAUSE WE NEED THEM FOR THE
RELIABILITY BUT IT SAID
INFORMATION THAT YOU HAVE THAT.
THIS IS A BAD DAY OR A BAD
SERIES OF THE IN SAN JOAQUIN CAN
WE TURN ON PLANTS [inaudible]
IN.
THE INLAND EMPIRE AND DO THAT
BALANCING ACT DO THE THAT THAT
DECISION HAVE THAT DATA ON HAND
THAT THE HERE DISTRICTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE.
OKAY SO.
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE IN YOUR
INTENT IS NOT.
TO SYSTEMATICALLY START SHUTTING
DOWN THESE PLANTS BUT I'M JUST
CURIOUS DO YOU HAVE A RESPONSE
TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
THAT HE BROUGHT UP SPECIFICALLY
RIGHT I MEAN I WOULD SAY FOR THE
THE SECOND SHOCK ABOUT
SUBPARAGRAPH HE AND SUBPARAGRAPH
HAVE I DO AGREE THAT THAT'S THE
ENERGY AND UTILITIES.
A A QUESTION.
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN THESE
PLANTS WERE GRANTED THEIR
PERMITS IT WAS FOR BASELOAD NOW
WERE IN THIS DIFFERENT WORD ON A
WORLD OF CYCLING THAT UP.
STARTING IN AND AND GOING UP AND
DOWN AND UP AND DOWN SO THERE'S
A DIFFERENT [inaudible]
POLLUTING --
CHARACTERISTIC THAT THE PLANTS
HAVE THAT DOESN'T EXIST WHEN YOU
JUST HAVE THE OLD DAYS WHEN YOU
JUST RAN THAT THE NATURAL GAS --
FACILITIES ALL OF ONE'S OKAY SO
THAT'S THAT'S GOING TO BE IF I'M
LUCKY THAT'S NEXT WEEK.
ON THE STUDY AND AND THAT THE
PARTY THREE TO MISS THEM WON THE
POT AND PART THREE IS YOU KNOW
WHO GETS TO CHOOSE WILL THAT'S
PART OF WHAT THE STUDY IS WE
WANT TO WE WANT TO GET AS A
INVENTORY AND AN ANALYSIS OF
WHERE ARE THEY HOW.
WHAT PLANTS ARE BEING USE WHAT
WHAT THE --
THE PLANTS ARE BEING CYCLE MORE
OFTEN WHAT'S THE USAGE OF WHAT'S
THE KNOCKS AND SOCKS AND ALL
THAT THAT THE POLLUTION SO IT'S
COMING OUT OF IT.
AND AGAIN THAT GETS BACK TO THE
NUMBER ONE IS THIS DATA I MEAN
IT'S REALLY UNUSABLE I MEAN THE
DATA NOW THESE FOLKS HAVE TO DO
A NEXT CELLS.
SHE AND RENTED OUT THEN TRY TO
MAKE CALCULATION SO WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW WE'RE IF WE CAN.
IMPROVE THE OPERATION I MEAN.
I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT THE ISA
WOULD SAY OH OKAY I GET IT WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
BAD HAIR DAYS AND IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ERIC.
AND AND IT'S WINDY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO LET'S JUST FLIP
AND THAT'S NOT THAT BIG OF A
DEAL MAYBE MY EXPERTS HAVE A
DIFFERENT.
OR MORE CLARIFYING BUT I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW I THINK YOU
ANSWERED IT WELL ENOUGH --
I JUST -- I
THINK YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THEIR
CERTAINLY SOME CONCERNS WITH
WHAT DIRECTION THIS BILL IS
GOING IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
STILL --
MAYBE WE LOOKING AT SOME
AMENDMENTS ARE NOW.
WELL I MEAN I GUESS I'VE GOT TO
GO TO ENERGY AND I'M I'M I'M
MINDFUL OF THAT THAT THIS IS
STEP ONE THAT THERE'S A STEP TO
THIS IS FOR THE AIR QUALITY.
AND KNOW THAT DATA A COLLECTION
IN THE STUDY ARE.
LET'S WORRISOME BECAUSE YOU
HAVEN'T YOU HAVE A FOCUS TO
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL WRAP THIS
UP I APOLOGIZE FOR TAKING ONE
MORE TIME THAN NORMAL --
IT'S THERE IS A GREATER AMOUNT
OF POLLUTION AND I THINK THE
DATA BEARS THIS OUT OF COURSE
YOU KNOW THERE'S THE GREATER
AMOUNT OF POLLUTION RETIREMENTS
COMING FROM AUTOMOBILES.
NOT FROM THESE PLANTS.
THE PLANTS WRECKED URBAN IT'S
PRETTY SMALL.
PERCENTAGE IN COMPARISON SO.
RIGHT I THINK PART OF THIS IF IF
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR IS THAT IS
THAT WE'RE HAVING DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT HER REGIONAL GRIT.
AND WHAT THIS IS GOING TO DO IS
THIS IS GOING TO GIVE US SOME
ARM.
OF PRINCIPLES THAT CALIFORNIA
STANDS FOR IN THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO BECAUSE NOT YOU KNOW I
WOULD AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION
THAT CALIFORNIA SENATE REALLY
GOOD CHANCE.
GOOD JOB OF UPDATING THEIR THEIR
AYE GAS FIRED PLANTS AND WE'VE
GOT IS LIKE SOMEBODY'S GOT A
BRAND NEW CARS RUNNING BETTER IN
THE FIFTEEN YEAR OLD CAR BELIEVE
WE'RE NOT GONNA.
BUT THIS WILL GIVE US SOME TOOLS
AND I WOULD APPLAUD THE
CALIFORNIA AND NATURAL GAS
PRODUCERSWHEN WE GET INTO
DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR NEIGHBORS
ABOUT A REGIONAL GRID.
THESE ARE GONNA BE SOME BASELINE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE WHERE WHERE ARE GAS.
FIRE PLANTER CLEAN IN YOUR GAS
FIRED PLANTS IN IN BE A US A I
GUESS WOULD BE CALLED THE
BASELINE THAT I'D LIKE THAT.
HAVE OUR STATE USE WE GET INTO
THESE DISCUSSIONS ON RELIABILITY
AND THE BENEFITS OF THE REGIONAL
GREAT DISCUSSION.
I THINK YOU.
SENATOR.
I'M I'M INTO MY CONCERNS MIGHT
BE MORE FOR NEXT COMMITTEE WHERE
I SIT ALSO.
AND BUT I'M.
I GUESS I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED
ABOUT SO I HAVE TO THE PLANTS
AND IN MY DISTRICT.
YOU PLANT AND I ALSO THE ONE IN
IN TRACY IS RIGHT.
ALMOST RIGHT ALONGSIDE THE
ALTIMA.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE COMMUTING FOUR
HOURS A DAY [inaudible]
EVERYDAY.
AND IT'S ALSO GOING TO BE.
A HUNDRED AND SEVEN SWEET.
SO WHAT IF YOU BEGIN USING AIR
CONDITIONERS.
SO IF WE'RE SAYING THAT IF THE
PLANTS ARE NEEDED TO KEEP
[inaudible]
EVERYTHING OPERATING.
THAT THEY CAN.
BUT IF THE AIR QUALITY IS TOO
BAD.
THEY CAN'T LIST THEY NEED IT.
THEN IT SEEMS LIKE WERE NOT YOU
NOT DOING THAT MUCH.
ON THE WORST DAYS YES ON THE ON
THE ON THE ON HUNDRED AND SEVEN
AND TRACY WHEN WHEN WE GOT
EVERYBODY HAVE THEIR AIR
CONDITIONING ON PROBABLY NOT.
PROBABLY NOT IT BUT IT'S ALL THE
IN BETWEEN STUFF.
IT'S ALL THE IN BETWEEN STEP
WERE NOT AT YOU KNOW AT A READY
THAT.
THE GREAT THREATEN READY TO POP
AND THAT YOU CAN HAVE THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE AIR
QUALITY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN IN THESE DIFFERENT REGIONS
AND SAY WELL.
YOU KNOW TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT
HOURS AHEAD YOU SEE THIS IS
REALLY GOOD TO BE BAD AND
STOCKTON AND WE WANT TO TURN ON
THESE UNITS IN --
THE INLAND EMPIRE OR UP IN
HUMBOLDT OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
TO GET THAT POWER ON THAT
[inaudible] TO TO A UNDERSCORE
THE RELIABILITY OF THE THE GRAD.
MAN I JUST PICKING ON YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE THERE DISARRAY AS
HE DOESN'T LIKE THIS BUT YOU
KNOW I MEAN THAT'S THE THAT'S
RIGHT THE IS THAT IS THAT WE
GET.
THESE MORE MICRO BY AIR QUALITY
POCKETS THAT WE KNOW ABOUT
TRYING.
TO TO COOPERATE WITH THE WITH
THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND THE
BALANCING AUTHORITY AND GIVING
THEM THE INFORMATION THEY MAKE
THAT MANY OF THE COMPUTER SOUTH
THEY'RE UNBELIEVABLE THAT THEY
MAKE THESE DECISIONS ON THAT
BALANCING IN THE DAY HAD MARKET
IN THE FIFTEEN MINUTE MARKET.
ON WHO NEEDS IT AND IS JUST
ANOTHER LITTLE INGREDIENT THAT
GOES IN ON WHAT'S THE AIR
QUALITY THERE AND TRACY I AT AT
THIS TIME ORG OR THE NEXT TWENTY
FOUR HOURS THAT'S REALLY WHERE I
WANT TO END UP.
UP WITH THIS IS THAT IT BECOMES
A A TOOL [inaudible]
RIGHT BUT BUT AS WE WHO
REPRESENTS THE VALLEY WE
FREQUENTLY HAVE AIR QUALITY ITS
THE NATURE OF THE VALLEY RIGHT.
THE BAY AREA BY HAS THOSE BIG --
FANS A BLOW EVERYTHING AND ARE
MY DISTRICT [inaudible]
ON SO ALSO THOUGH BUT IT IN
CREATING I MEAN SO SO THAT'S
GOING TO BE GIVEN EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT THAT THE AIR QUALITY IN THE
VALLEY IS IS IS NOT A NOT GREAT
AND THAT NOTHING THAT'S OKAY BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF ERRORS.
OTHER VARIABLES THAT IMPACT THAT
SUCH AS AGRICULTURE SUCH AS CAR
SUCH AS DIESEL SUCH AS
EVERYTHING ELSE AND JUST AGAIN
YOU'RE YOU'RE LIVING IN A BOWL.
BUT BUT BUT I I HOPE WE'RE NOT
SAYING SOMETHING LIKE BECAUSE
WITH MY TWO PLANTS WAS A PEOPLE
WHO ARE WHO ARE WORKING.
AND EVEN THOUGH WE WANT GOOD AIR
QUALITY WE ALSO WANT.
THE JOBS REMAIN AND PEOPLE HAVE
MADE A LOT OF INVESTMENTS IN
THOSE PLANTS ARE MOST OF A MARK
OVER FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AT THE
HUGE AMOUNT INVESTMENTS PEOPLE
ARE WORKING THEY'RE GETTING.
GOOD PAYING GOOD JOBS AND WHAT
DO WE DO IT TO THE MARKET AND
WHAT WE DO THE INDUSTRY WHEN WE
SAY NOW THINGS ARE GONNA HAVE TO
START.
ALRIGHT YOU'RE OFF YOUR ON YOUR
OFF YOUR OWN AND WHAT DOES THAT
DO [inaudible]
THE OVERALL [inaudible]
THE PEACE OF MIND EMPLOYMENT
STABILITY ALTHOUGH RIGHT TO WEAR
BETTER BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
TRANSPORT OUR JOBS TO THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
PART OF THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
MISHAP MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
WHEN WE REACH OUR RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARDS MEAN WE'VE
WE'VE ALREADY MADE THAT VOTE ON
40% 50% IN THE CHANGE WITH THE
THE UTILITIES HAVING TO HAVE A
BLEND OF MORE.
AYE SOLAR AND RENEWABLE THAT'S
THAT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE WITH
WITH THAT.
SB SIXTY FOUR S. B. SIXTY FOUR
HAS THE WRINKLE IF I MAY OF
GIVING US INFORMATION ABOUT THE
AIR QUALITY IN ALL THESE
DIFFERENT SUBSECTIONS BECAUSE IT
MAY BE.
NOT TURNING ON A CALPINE IN
HAYWARD BECAUSE IT'S THE WIND IS
BLOWING IN THIS COULD EXACERBATE
STOCKTON AND TRACY VERSUS
TURNING ON THE FACILITY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR OR MID
STATE BECAUSE THAT MAKES SENSE
IT'S JUST.
IT'S IT'S STUDYING THOSE THOSE
THINGS IN THE STUDY BUT AND THE
DATA AND THEN JUST THAT
COOPERATION.
WITH THE LOCAL AIRPORTS IN THE
CASE SO WHICH DOESN'T EXIST NOW.
AIRPORTS HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION BUT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THEY HAVEN'T DONE MODELING
STUDIES.
ON AMID THEY HAVE THE
INFORMATION ABOUT AIR QUALITY.
RIGHT IT JUST ITCHES USABLE I
GUESS IS THE IS IS SO THAT WE
CAN WE CAN --
UNDERSTAND IT AND THIS IS AN
ELEMENT THAT WE'D LIKE TO FOR
THEM TO CONSIDER I'M NOT TRYING
TO COMPROMISE RELIABILITY THAT'S
THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S NOT THE GOAL HERE IS JUST
TO SAY IF THERE'S A CHANCE THAT
YOU CAN TURN OFF INSTEAD OF
USING THE TREES TO FACILITY YOU
CAN USE.
ONE AND ANOTHER PART OF AND
STILL HAVE RELIABILITY AND YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHEN WE HAVE THOSE.
BAD HAIR DAYS HITS FOR SEVERAL
DAYS IN A ROW IN ITS NICHE
DECEMBER AND JANUARY AND THAT
KNOCKS ON JUST STARTING UP ONE
OF THESE I THINK IT'S AND THIS
IS LIKE THIRTY EIGHT TIMES OF
WHAT IT IS OR ITS EQUIVALENT OF
THIRTY EIGHT HOURS.
RUNNING IT AS A NORMAL WAY THAT
WE WOULD RUN A GAS FIRED PLANT
VERSUS TURNING UP TURNING IT OFF
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE TRICK IS
THE MANAGEMENT OF THESE ASSETS
--
THAT WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING US
WITH ENERGY AS WE MOWER WE'VE D.
CARBONIZED ARE.
ARE RUN.
ECONOMY TO EATEN US REQUESTS AND
AND NO END OF PERHAPS YOU CAN'T
ABOUT WHAT DOES THAT DO. FOR THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE MADE ALL THIS
INVESTMENT AND THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WORKING THERE WE START
CYCLING OFTEN ON A DIFFERENT.
AND TRANSFERRING AROUND WHAT
DOES THAT DO. TO THE INVESTMENTS
ARE MADE TO THESE FACILITIES.
THAT HAVE GONE ALONG THAT BETTER
BUT A NEW GENERATION TO WHAT THE
OLD FACILITIES WHERE.
SO IF IF I MAY JUMP IN JUST A
LITTLE BIT SO THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING UP THE FACT THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
WITHIN WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
ELECTRICITY SYSTEM THINGS ARE
MOVING VERY QUICKLY AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT THE
CONTRIBUTION OF CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTION.
FROM THE GAS FLEET IS RELATIVELY
LOW COMPARED TO MORE MOBILE
SOURCE SAYS BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THAT COULD CHANGE OVER TIME
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE
PLANTS ARE CYCLING SO OFTEN.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
JUST MAKE IT MORE POSSIBLE FOR
THE AIR DISTRICTS TO DO ANALYSIS
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND.
HOW THE INCREASE IN CYCLING
COULD BE IMPACTING AIR QUALITY
IN THEIR BASINS ANYONE AND THE
PART OF THE PUT THE LAST PART OF
THE BILL THAT SAYS?
THAT P. YOU SEEN THIS C. E. C.
SHALL WORK TOGETHER TO DO A
STUDY ON WHAT THE LONG TERM
TURNED OUT OF GAS INEVITABLY
INEVITABLY WILL LOOK LIKE IS IN
PART TO PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY
TO THE MARKET.
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE HEADED BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW ABOUT.
DO WE NEED THIS PLANT THE PLANT
CAN OPERATE BASED ON WHAT IT'S
GETTING PAID FOR RIGHT NOW SHE
WE GIVE IT MORE MONIES THAT CAN
AND DO RETROFITS TO CONTINUE
RUNNING BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
NECESSARY FOR RELIABILITY.
IS OUR DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVE
THERE'S A LOT OF HAPHAZARD
DECISIONS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
AND THE STATE DOESN'T HAVE.
A LONG TERM PLAN FOR THAT TURNED
OUT OF GAS WHICH WE'VE COMMITTED
TO THROW CLIMATE POLICIES.
THAT MEANS THAT THE PLAN IS ONE
THING BUT THEN WHEN WHEN YOU
START TALKING ABOUT.
HER THEN YOU CAN CHECK THIS ONE
OFTEN TURN OVER THERE SO SO
YOU'RE SAYING.
THE THE THE FUTURE IS UNCERTAIN
AND THIS IS ONE OF OUR OWN A AN
ATTEMPT.
AT EXPERIMENTATION OF THE FUTURE
WHO KNOWS WHAT THE CURRENT
CURRENTLY IT'S UNCERTAIN YOU
KNOW THE CASE SO CHU SAYS WE
WANT YOU TO RAMP UP WE WANT YOU
TO SHUT DOWN THEY THEY DO THAT
ON A RELIABILITY WHICH IS ADDING
ANOTHER BLEND OF WELL.
LET'S LOOK AT THE AIR QUALITY
WHEN WE MAKE THAT DECISION OR
GET THAT GET THAT INFORMATION
THEIR QUALITY BECAUSE IT IS.
IT IS UNCERTAIN RIGHT NOW THAT
SOME OF THESE PLANTS IN
DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT REGIONS
ARE STRUGGLING BECAUSE THEY WERE
GONNA GET SO MANY PEOPLE WORKING
AND THEY IF THEY'RE ONLY
OPERATING THREE DAYS SINCE OF
SEVEN DAYS THAT'S A ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
THAT'S GOING ON WITH THEIR
WITHOUT S. B. SIXTY FOUR WE'RE
SAYING THAT LET'S PUT IN BECAUSE
IT MIGHT BE THAT ONE OF THOSE
PLANS.
THAT IS NOT OPERATING SO OFF SO
OFTEN BECAUSE OF THE RELATIVE
AIR QUALITY MIGHT GET.
RAMPED UP IN THE STUDY MAY SHOW
THAT THAT THIS IS THE THIS IS
THE TO ONE FACILITY IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S THE FIRST TO RETIRE
BECAUSE OF THESE.
OTHER FACTORS AND THE AIR
QUALITY.
ALRIGHT SIR MCCARTY.
THINK THAT I DIDN'T SEE THE AIR
AIR BOARD I MEAN IN THE AIR
QUALITY.
DISTRICT FIT GROUP WAS A CALLED
CAP GO CAT GO OUT.
KEPCO IT'S LATE MEANS NETWORKING
CAN CO I DIDN'T SEE THEM UP
HERE.
IN THE LINE UP AND THEY'RE THE
ONES WHO ARE A BIG PART OF THIS
--
HAVE YOU BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
AND WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT BEING
THE ENTITY THAT WOULD BE.
AT THE FRONT LINES WORKING ON
THIS.
OKAY SO WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH AIR DISTRICTS
WE HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION WITH
SOUTH BECAUSE I PERSONALLY HAVE
NOT HAD A CONVERSATION WITH CAP
COLA BUT I THINK. TO PARAPHRASE
A CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD
THEY'VE THEY RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
COULD BE AN ISSUE IN FACT SOUTH
COAST HAS PUT SOME ANNUAL
LIMITATIONS ON START STOPS
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS I HAVE ON ON
KNOCKS ISSUES.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IT'S AN
ANNUAL LIMITATION ON START STOPS
IT'S NOT CONNECTED TO THE WORST
AIR QUALITY DAYS SO.
SO THEORETICALLY THE LIMITATION
COULD STILL ALLOW THE PLANT TO
START STOP IN THE DAYS THAT
WOULD.
WHERE STARTING AND STOPPING
WOULD EXACERBATE AIR QUALITY I
THINK BY THE AIR DISTRICTS HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IS IT TO WRAP UP?
WRAP UP THE DATA THAT'S
CURRENTLY BEING YEAH A AND MAKE
IT MORE ACCESSIBLE THEY DO THEY
ARE GETTING THAT DATA FROM EPA.
BUT WHAT THE BILL WOULD DO WOULD
BE TO REQUIRE THAT IT BECOME
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND USER
FRIENDLY.
SO IN OTHER SOME QUESTIONS.
ABOUT WHO DOES THAT WHERE THEY
HAVE AN EXPRESS ANY CONCERNS ON
THE TECHNICAL ASPECT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION NOT YET THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN IN THE OFFICE
FRIEDMAN DEALING WITH THE
SPONSORS AND YET PROVIDING THEM
WITH INFORMATION BUT NO.
IF I MAY MR MCCARTY --
I SEE REPRESENTATIVE CAPITAL IN
THE BAY AREA.
AIR DISTRICT IT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO COME FORWARD AND A PROVIDE
ANY.
OKAY JUST EXTENDING THE
INVITATION [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
THERE WILL.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
TOM EDISON WITH THE BAY AREA
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I'M
HAPPY TO TRY DAY ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE DAY YEAR
YEAR DISTRICT DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL --
WE CERTAINLY HAVE A LOT OF
THOUGHTS ABOUT.
PETER PLANTS ARE EMISSIONS
COMPETE HER PLANS.
I DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
STRATEGIES FOR PAST IMPROVING
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND REDUCING A MEASURE IN THE
SOCIETY INCLUDING FROM POWER
GENERATION --
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I'M ALAN ABBAS --
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION NOW
REPRESENTING THE ITHIRTY FIVE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS.
AGAIN CAP CHO HASN'T TAKEN A
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE HAVEN'T
--
RECEIVE DATA ABOUT WHAT WE
HAVEN'T --
GOTTEN GUIDANCE FROM --
THE THE AIR DISTRICTS ON A WE DO
HAVE OTHER ARE SOME SOME THINGS
IN THIS BILL THAT WOULD BE VERY
CHALLENGING FOR AIR DISTRICTS
AND TO I'D ALSO BE ABLE.
TO TALK WITH THE THE COMMITTEE
ABOUT -- HOW
WHERE DISTRICTS PERMIT THESE
FACILITIES AND WHAT WE DO --
IN PREPARATION MAKE A PERMIT AND
HOW WE'VE ALREADY DONE SOME OF
THESE THINGS THAT WE THINK THE
BILL -- ASKS
US TO DO [inaudible]
THANK.
I'M SORRY MR MCCARTY I DIDN'T
MEAN TO INTERRUPT BUT ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEIR DISTRICTS OBVIOUSLY.
THE GOAL HERE.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER Y. CASKEY I WANTED --
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL TO ADDRESS
OBVIOUSLY A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
WHICH IS THE IMPACT OF THE THE
NATURAL GAS POWER PLANTS
PARTICULARLY ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND AND FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE I LIKE HOW YOU TRY
[inaudible]
TO SEPARATE THE MISSION OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE FROM
THE MISSION PERHAPS OF THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
BUT OBVIOUSLY WE COME TO THIS --
DYESS A YOU KNOW WITH CONCERNS
--
THAT MAY CROSS OVER --
FROM THE AIR QUALITY ISSUES TO
THE ENERGY ISSUES MY PRIMARY
CONCERN IS --
AS WE HEARD FROM THE REPRESENTED
FROM CAP CO --
WHETHER THIS --
IT'S IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE YOU
ARE A ATTEMPTING TO PROVIDE A
SOLUTION TO A VERY IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
PROBLEM BUT I'M NOT SURE IF THE
SOLUTION THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING
[inaudible]
HIS WORKABLE.
A WE HEARD WHEN CAP GO THAT --
THAT.
YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE SOME.
EXTREME CHALLENGES AND
IMPLEMENTING.
I PARTICULARLY THIS SIR.
THE SYSTEM WELFARE DISTRICTS --
ISSUING TWENTY FOUR HOUR NOTICE
IN COORDINATING THAT WITH THE
BALANCING AUTHORITIES --
AND SO -- I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU --
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE FEASIBILITY
IN THE WORKABILITY.
OF THIS SYSTEM.
THIS -- NAM.
INCREASED COOPERATION THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE BETWEEN AIR
DISTRICTS AND AT THE BALANCING
AUTHORITY.
WELL I'M I MEAN YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO TO WORK WITH DEAR
DISTRICTS THEY PROVIDE US WITH
YOU KNOW NOTICED THE PUBLIC WHEN
WE HAVE A YOU KNOW A SMOG DAY
THAT WERE.
WERE NOT SUPPOSED TO GO OUTSIDE
NAY WARN OUR KIDS AND AND AND
THEY DO IT AND IT'S IT SEEMS TO
BE THAT YOU KNOW I MIGHT BE
WRONG ON THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR.
A NOTICE I PICKED A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
WITH THE ACT CASE SO WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY WE DON'T.
SET UP THERE A DELIVERY OF THEIR
ENERGIES AND THE NEXT THE NEXT
DAY ON WHAT THEY DECIDE
[inaudible]
TO A CYCLE UPTURN AND CYCLE DOWN
--
YOU DON'T.
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE YOU KNOW
THE CHALLENGES OF CLIMATE CHANGE
SOMETIMES IT'S IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TECH TO COME
WITH AN ANSWER MAYBE OF A LITTLE
ABSTRACT THAT WERE A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO SAY OKAY.
YOU YOU FOLKS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO WORK TOGETHER BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IF THERE'S
SOMETHING CONCRETE.
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED IN THE
BILL THAT MAKES IT UNWORKABLE
I'M.
I'M ALL EARS SADDAM I'M A
WILLING TO TO DO THAT BUT THE A
FOUNDATION OF IT THAT WE NEED TO
GET THIS DATA WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF STUDY WE NEED TO
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS.
AND WE NEED TO COORDINATE WITH
THE AIR DISTRICT AND THE AND THE
CASE SO I THINK THOSE WHO.
THOSE ARE --
DESIRABLE AND AND AGAIN AS I HAD
SAID MENTIONED TO A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER --
MELINDA'S WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING REGIONALLY WITH OUR
PARTNERS AND IT'S GOOD TO BE.
IMPERATIVE THAT WE THEIR DEAD
ADAM WE HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
QUITE FRANKLY.
AS AS CLEAN.
A DANCING MACHINE AS BECAUSE OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL LOS WE'VE PUT
UP THERE BEFORE.
SO I MAYBE YEAH NO JUST ADD THEM
BECAUSE IT DOES SEEM LIKE
THERE'S SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THIS WOULD ACTUALLY WORKING IN
REAL TIME SO THE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR NOTICE IS MEANT. TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANY DECISION ABOUT --
AN AIR AND AIR DISTRICT PLACING
A LIMITATION ON THE ABILITY OF A
POWER PLANT TO START UP WOULD
HAPPEN WELL IN ADVANCE OF THE
AYE SO SETTING THEIR DISPATCH
STACK FOR THE DAY HAD ENERGY
MARKET SO.
OTHER WOMAN FROM THE CHAMBER
MENTIONED THAT YOU KNOW GREAT
RELIABILITY DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE MINUTE BY MINUTE THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE AND NOTHING
ABOUT THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE
THAT.
ABILITY OF THE GRID OPERATOR TO
MAKE THOSE MINUTE BY MINUTE
DECISIONS THIS IS ALL PHYSICALLY
IMPACTING WHAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DAY HAD
ELECTRICITY MARKET.
AND THE OTHER INTENT IS FOR THE
AIR DISTRICTS TO DO AN ANALYSIS
UP FRONT OF WHEN GENERATION MAY
BE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTING AIR
QUALITY SO THAT WE'RE NOT
STARTING FROM A BLANK SLATE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THAT WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA
OF WHAT POWER PLANTS WE MIGHT BE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT TIMES OF THE
YEAR MIGHT BE MOST PROBLEMATIC
SO THAT.
WE GO WELL INTO THE WEE GO INTO
SEASONS WELL IN ADVANCE
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE OPTIONS
ARE WHAT THE ALTERNATIVES ARE SO
THAT IT'S NOT JUST MAKING THESE
FLY BY NIGHT DECISIONS ARE AND I
APPRECIATE [inaudible]
TO IT OF THE AUTHORS EPCIS ON
THE THE PLANNING AND THE DATA I
THINK THE PROBLEM ARISES WHEN
YOU.
ARE AS MISTER SPUTNIK JONES
INDICATED ARE GIVING THE POWER
TO THE AIR DISTRICTS. TWO
ENFORCE THESE OPERATING LIMITS
--
AND AND AND AND AND SAID I THINK
THERE IS A LEGITIMATE QUESTION
AS TO WHETHER THE AIR DISTRICTS
ARE IN THE BEST POSITION TO BE
--
DOING THAT JOB OF OF BALANCING
THE POWER --
WHAT THEY WHICH HAS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN AND THE THE
JURISDICTION OF OF OF THE N.
NELSON AND IS EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM KNOWS?
THIS IS A TOUGH PILL IN NATURAL
RESOURCES AND THIS COULD BE A
TOUGHER BILL AND ENERGY IN A A
UTILITY SO I I UNDERSTAND THAT
I'VE TALKED WITH THE OPPOSITION
THEN AND WERE WELL AWARE BUT
I'M.
TRYING TO TO DEAL WIT THE AIR
QUALITY PORTIONS OF IT AND THE
DESIRABILITY OF OF IT IN AND
DEAL WITH PART TWO ERIC WELL I
ALSO SIT ON THE GO THE I KNOW I
KNOW IT AND SOME GIVING A
PREVIEW ACROSS OVER.
SORRY IF I MIGHT --
I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
UNDER THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT
AND THE STATE CLEAN OUR CLEAN
AIR ACT THE AIR DISTRICTS HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY SPECIFICALLY.
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE
STATIONARY SOURCES NONE OF THEM
ARE OPERATING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
VIOLATIONS OF AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS THAT'S REALLY ALL THAT
WE'RE ASKING TO HAVE HAPPEN HERE
SO IT'S TRUE AS AND THE KEPT HER
REPRESENTATIVE.
STATED --
REQUIREMENTS ARE ALREADY WITHIN
THE PURVIEW OF THE AIR DISTRICTS
WHAT'S NEW IS THIS COMMUNICATION
VEHICLE I WAS VERY INTERESTED TO
HEAR THAT POWER PLANTS WOULD
REFUSE TO RUN.
IF ASKED TO DO SO BY CHI SO EVEN
THOUGH THE SO DID THE CITY THE
SITUATION OF CONTEMPLATED IS
THAT THE AIR DISTRICTS IN FORMA
PESO PESO THEN HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY NO.
WE NEED THESE FOR RELIABILITY IF
THE AIR DISTRICT IF.
POWER PLANTS THEN REFUSED TO RUN
I THINK THAT WOULD NOT BE A
RESULT OF THIS PARTICULAR LAW
THAT WOULD BE SOME OTHER KIND OF
DECISION MAKING.
IRATE.
WELL LET ME LET ME JUST
CONCLUDE.
BY SAYING THAT I YOU KNOW
SUPPORT WHO EAT THE OBJECTIVE OF
YOUR BILL AND FOR THAT REASON LP
--
RECOMMENDING GO --
EH DO PASS --
WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
ACCEPTED --
AND WITH THIS CONVERSATION TO
CONTINUE AND I HOPE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL FOLLOW
YOUR LEAD THANK YOU WOULD YOU
LIKE FLETCHER URGE NO I AIR
TONIGHT VOTE I'M.
I'M AVAILABLE ON AT NIGHT
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
CONSIDERATION COMMITTEE.
MADAM SECRETARY SCHOLAR.
ITEM ONE SB SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE I ALRIGHT FIVE ONE THE
BILLS ON CALL OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY HAY [inaudible]
POSSIBLE [inaudible]
REMEDY [inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
COMMITTEE I APOLOGIZE SO WE HAD
A SLIGHT OVERSIGHT IN THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON ON THAT AND OKAY SO
WITH BE MOTION MADE BY MS RACE A
SECOND ABOUT MUSLIM ON WE NEED A
RECALL.
THE ADMISSION NEED TO RECALL THE
ROLE YEAH OKAY ALRIGHT SO WE DO
NEED -- TO
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN [inaudible]
MY APOLOGIES ITEM ONE SB SIXTY
FOUR SENATOR MAJKOWSKI TO PASS
AT THEM MENDED REFER TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS REFUGEES AYE MURATSUCHI
AYE ACOSTA CHILD [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FLORA NO [inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMON I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
PRESS I STONE [inaudible]
STONE I FIVE ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS --
BEFORE BEGINS TO LET YOU KNOW WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED PARENTS AND
TAKE YOUR STAFF. FOR YOUR WORK.
ON MY MEASURE WITH S. B. TEN
THIRTEEN WE ARE NARROWING IN ON
THE ON THE LEAST KNOWN BUT MOST
IN PART.
FOR SUPER POLLUTANTS SP
TENTATIVE ESTABLISHES AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO PROMOTE
pREDUCTANT EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS.
S. B. TEN THIRTEEN ALSO
BACKSTOPS THE EPA SNAP RULES ON
AGENCIES THAT WERE VACATED THIS
FALL -- THE
EPA SNAPROLLS WERE FINALIZED
AFTER PUBLIC RULE MAKING PROCESS
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN DURING THE EPA
PROCESS CHARGE SIZE RULES CAME
UP AS A PEER REGULATORY HURDLE
FOR THE TRANSITION OF
RESIDENTIAL REFRIGERATORS TO
BETTER.
REFRIGERANTS THE SNAPPED A LINE
OF TWENTY TWO SIZE WOULD BE
INCREASED IN TWENTY TWO OR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO ALIGN WITH
THE REST OF THE WORLD.
YET EPA DID NOT ACT AND I IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS EXPECTED AND
WE BELIEVE THEY WORE INSTEAD ACT
LATER THIS YEAR.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS DELAY HAS
DELAYED THE ABILITY OF COMPANIES
TO PREPARE FOR THE DEADLINES ARE
FOR THE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKING
TODAY REVISED THE DEADLINES FOR
THE HOUSEHOLD REFRIGERATORS.
APPROVAL TO PROVIDE A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FOUR FOUR SIDE REFRIGERATORS AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOUR BUILT
IN REFRIGERATORS THESE
AMENDMENTS --
WILL BE ADDED IN THE BILL --
IN THE COMMITTEE THE CHANGE IN
THE DEADLINE ACKNOWLEDGES THE
CLEAR REGULATORY HURDLE AND
PROVIDES A PATHWAY FOR
TRANSITION TO ISOBUTANE
ISOBUTANE --
HAS A GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL
OF THREE A CURRENT AGENCIES HAVE
A GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL OF
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WE HAVE ALSO
CLARIFY THAT THE AIR BE HAS THE
AUTHORITY.
AND FLEXIBILITY TO MODIFY THE
SNAP DEADLINES TO ACHIEVE OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND RESPOND
THE TO AVAILABLE ALTERNATIVES.
AND MEMBERS IN A WE WE SEE THE
LATE LETTER OF OPPOSITION FROM
CERTAIN MANUFACTURERS OF UNITARY
AIR CONDITIONING SYSTEMS.
HOWEVER THE EPA SNAP ROLLS DO
NOT COVER THESE APPLICATIONS AND
THEREFORE ARE OUTSIDE THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL.
THAT IS A SEPARATE AIR BE ISSUE
AND THE BILL.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND FOR THE WORK AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE TO A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB.
TEN THIRTEEN S. B. TURN TEN
THIRTEEN PROVIDE CERTAINTY IN
LEADERSHIP ANDREDUCING A MAJOR
DRIVER OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
AGENCIES ARE AND CAN BE
THOUSANDS OF TIMES MORE POTENT A
TRAPPING HEAT IN THE ATMOSPHERE
THAN CO.
TWO AND WORSE STILL THEY DO
THEIR DAMAGE QUICKLY AND THEIR
USES VOTE ON THE RISE BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE WORLD.
TO RESPOND TO THE THREAT THE EPA
ESTABLISHED DEADLINES FOR
PHASING OUT EACH OF THE THE
MAJOR AND USES WERE ALTERNATIVES
EXIST.
AS PART OF ITS NOT PROGRAM
ETCETERA ARE EXPLAINED HOWEVER
THAT FEES DOWN WAS RECENTLY
THROWN INTO LEGAL LIMBO CREATING
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY.
BY ADOPTING IT INTO STATE LAW SB
TEN THIRTEEN WILL KEEP THE GOAL
POSTS IN PLACE AND CREATE A
TEMPLATE FOR OTHER STATES TO
FOLLOW AND PROVIDE MARKETS
ANSWER AT MARKET CERTAINTY.
THE CERTAINTY AFFORDED BY THIS
BILL IS ALSO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT RULES ARE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S PLANNED TO
FEES DOWN EACH OF THESE ADELINE
WITH A STATUTORY.
TARGETS ADOPTED INFALLIBLE.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHAT
ARABIC COULD ADOPT THESE RULES
YOUR REGULATION GOING THROUGH
ANOTHER MAJOR ROLE MAKING
DUPLICATES EPA'S PROCESS WILL
ADD FURTHER UNCERTAINTY AND
DELAY. TO THE PRODUCTION
SCHEDULE THAT MEANS THOSE
FOREGONE REDUCTIONS WILL NEED TO
BE MADE UP ALMOST CERTAINLY A
GREATER COST.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO BLOCKS BACKS
LATER CLIMATE STRATEGIES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND IF WE CAN.
THIRTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS TOM MORRIS I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
HONEYWELL'S FLOORING PRODUCTS
DIVISION.
HONEYWELL IS A LEADING PRODUCER
FLOOR CARBON REFRIGERANTS
BLOWING AGENTS AEROSOL
PROPELLANTS I'M HERE TODAY FOR
EXPERT TO EXPRESS HONEYWELL
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL.
TEN THIRTEEN I'VE BEEN WITH
HONEYWELL FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
THREE YEARS AND HAVE LED THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF SEVERAL
INNOVATIVE REFRIGERANTS
INCLUDING R. FOR TEN A WHICH IS
USED IN HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AIR CONDITIONERS ROUND THE
WORLD.
HONEYWELL IS LONG RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING
AGENCIES THEIR IMPACT ON GLOBAL
WARMING.
AS THESE REGULATIONS WERE
PROMULGATED AT EPA WE MADE A
BUSINESS DECISION NOT TO SIT
IDLE WE DID WHAT WE DO WE DECIDE
TO MOVE FORWARD TO INNOVATE.
IN ORDER TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THIS REAL
CLIMATE PROBLEM. TO THAT END
HONEYWELL AND OTHERS HAVE SPENT
MORE THAN ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
IDENTIFY AND COMMERCIALIZE.
THE RANGE OF LOW IN REDUCED GWB
PRODUCTS THAT CAN REPLACE MANY
OF THE HIGH GLOBAL WARMING
PRODUCTS IN USE TODAY OVER A
BROAD RANGE OF APPLICATIONS.
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR LARA AND
THE OTHER SUPPORTERS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANKS GOOD EVENING OF KEVIN
MASTER OF THEM WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF HOME APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS [inaudible]
AND WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY
THIS IS A CHANGE OF OUR POSITION
OF PEOPLE HEARD OF AND I CREDIT
THAT TO CENTER LARA'S LEADERSHIP
IN THE IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
TO REALLY I THINK THIS IS A CASE
EXAMPLE THAT EVERYBODY ON THIS
COMMITTEE SHE WOULD SUPPORT
ENCOURAGE WHERE.
PEOPLE LISTEN AND WE TALK AND WE
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
GOOD FOR CLIENTS MANUFACTURES
GOOD FOR AN RTC I THINK THIS IS
A REAL WIN FOR EVERYBODY TODAY.
IDEAS FOR AUSTIN THAT I HOPE YOU
SUPPORT IT THIS IS FOR US.
IMPACTING EVERY HOUSEHOLD
REFRIGERATOR IT'S IN EVERY HOME
AND IT CAN BE A SHOWCASE FOR
HOUSE CAN BE DONE RIGHT --
WE CAN GET THERE WE JUST NEEDED
TO HAVE SOME ISSUES WHICH CHARGE
SIZES AT EPA IT'S A TECHNICAL
ENGINEERING ISSUE.
AND THANK THE SENATOR LAURIE HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT AND UNDERSTANDS
IT AND I HAVE LETTERS HERE FROM
[inaudible]
GEE [inaudible]
ELECTROLUX [inaudible]
WHIRLPOOL --
INDIA.
PSH BOSCH SIEMENS LOCATED IN
IRVINE [inaudible]
L. G..
DANFOSS THEY'RE ALL SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS THIS IS THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL IT PROVIDE
CERTAINTY AND ALLOWS US TO GET
TO THE CLIMATE FRIENDLY
REFRIGERANTS.
IN IRAQ IN THE RIGHT WAY THAT
EVERYBODY CAN WIN SO WE'RE
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AND A REALLY
KARGES SHOULD BE.
A REALLY EASY VOTE FOR EVERYONE
HOPEFULLY THANK YOU.
I AM RIGHT ON THE OUT SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA SEAL CV AND ETF
SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING PEOPLE COMING IN
BEHALF OF INGERSOLL RAND AND TO
OUR TRAIN BUSINESS WHEN THE
LARGEST MANUFACTURERS OF
CHILLERS AND UNITED STATES BEGIN
TRANSITIONING TO NEXT GENERATION
CHILLERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WILL
HAVE A FULL SUITE.
I HAVE A JEWELERS ON THE MARKET
NEXT DURATION CHILLERS BY TWENTY
TWENTIES IS A GREAT BILL MERGER
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMERCIAL COMPANY CHEMICAL
COMPANY IN THE REFRIGERANT SPACE
AND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MCCLOSKEY ON BEHALF OF* HERE
IN SUPPORT.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL PLEASE COME
.
FOR I I CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MIKE HEALTH PARLIAMENT THE
BALKAN GROUP I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF CARRIER CORPORATION AND
UNITED TECHNOLOGIES ANOTHER ONE
OF THE LARGEST MANUFACTURERS OF
CHILLERS AND UNITARY EACH BACK
PRODUCTS.
THINK IT'S OUR LETTER THAT THAT
--
THE SENATOR MENTIONED --
WE ARE MANUFACTURERS MAJOR
MANUFACTURERS CHILLERS --
THERE BE STIRRED ACTIVITY WHICH
WHICH IS ALREADY OUT THERE IN
TERMS OF RIGHT THE PROMULGATION
THEY'VE THEY'VE ADOPTED --
SAP TWENTY THAT THEY'RE
PROPOSING TO ADOPT SNAP --
TWENTY ONE THE PRELIMINARY RIGS
THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW CONCEPTS ARE OUT THERE
AND IT SHOWS THEY ARE BE NEEDING
TO SURPASS THE TIMELINES AND
SNAP. TWENTY ONE FOR CHILLERS
WHICH WE MANUFACTURE.
IN THAT TERM --
THEIR TRAJECTORY IN THEIR
EXPLORATION GOES BEYOND WHAT WAS
NEGOTIATED WITH THE US EPA ON
THESE ISSUES --
CODES AND STANDARDS SUCH AS FIRE
CODES IN THE UNIVERSAL MAKING
AND THE UNIFORM A CANTICLE CODE.
WILL NOT BE IN PLACE.
FOR POTENTIALLY FLAMMABLE.
OR POTENTIALLY MORE TOXIC
[inaudible]
REFRIGERANTS.
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THAT'S
THAT'S THE TIME WHEN THAT AIR
HE'S LOOKING FOR NOW I
UNDERSTAND AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED IN REGARDS TO
ALLOWING DISCRETION.
LAST SET HAD ACCELERATE WHICH
CAUSED OUR CONCERN.
NOW IF WE ARE WILLING TO LOCK IN
CERTAIN TIMELINES FOR CERTAIN
PRODUCTS INCLUDING TWENTY TWENTY
NINE FOR UNITARY PRODUCTS AS
NEGOTIATED WITH.
GINA MCCARTHY WHEN SHE IS THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE US EPA I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WERE WILLING. TO TO
MOVE SITES AS WELL AS OTHERS
HAVE HAVE [inaudible]
DONE.
BUT AT THIS TIME PART ARE PRETTY
PREDOMINANT CONCERN IS STILL THE
SAFETY OF THE EMPLOYEES AND THAT
THEN THE PEOPLE IN THE BUILDINGS
AND UNITS.
THAT WILL HAVE THESE
REFRIGERANTS THAT THAT ARE
POTENTIALLY TOXIC AND
POTENTIALLY FLAMMABLE WHEN
COMPARED TO THE CURRENT.
IN COMMON USE MATERIALS.
AND O FOR THAT I THINK THERE'S
A COUPLE OTHERS THAT THAT WILL
EXPRESSED SIMILAR CONCERNS BUT
IT BUT WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR WE
ARE WE ARE THE LARGEST
MANUFACTURERS OF OF CHILLERS AND
UNITARY AGE FACTS AND WE WE DO
YOU BELIEVE THE AIR BE IS GOING
BEYOND.
WHAT THE CO TIMINGS ARE THERE
WILL NOT BE ADOPTED CODES FOR
THESE FLAMMABLE UNITS BY THAT
TIME?
AND IF WE'RE WILLING TO LOCK
THAT IN AND NOT GIVE AIR BE THE
DISCRETION TO MOVE TIMELINES ON
US.
THEN WE CAN CERTAINLY.
TALK ABOUT MOVING OUR POSITION
BUT AT THIS POINT GIVING THEM
THE SOLE DISTRACTION WHEN
THEY'RE NOT EXPERTS ON EACH
BACK.
CC MIGHT BE.
BUT BUT I'M NOT GONNA GIVE THAT
AUTHORITY TO THE AIR BE.
ARE BEFORE WE GO FOR IT THERE --
AS IS STANDARD PROCEDURE WE
ALLOW THE SUPPORTERS IN
OPPOSITION THREE IS TWO MINUTES
EACH [inaudible]
SO.
I SEE FOR SETTLEMENTS IS SEATED
THERE YOU ARE.
SELECT AMONG YOURSELVES WHO
WANTS TO BE THE NEXT.
A MEDIUM IN THIS WEEK WHICH I
THOUGHT JUST REAL QUICK CHRIS
WALKER BEHALF THE SHEET METAL
AIR CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS
REPRESENTING FOUR HUNDRED
CONTRACTOR STATEWIDE.
POINT TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND MEN
WOMEN -- WE
FOLLOW CODE AND IN CALIFORNIA WE
FOLLOW THE CALIFORNIA MECHANICAL
CODE WHICH IS BASED ON THE
UNIFORM MECHANICAL CODE ADOPTED
EVERY THREE YEARS WE CANNOT BE
WORKING ON SYSTEMS THAT DO NOT
FOLLOW CODE COMPLIANCE.
SO WHAT WE HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
WHERE WE'RE AT POSE UNLESS
AMENDED A WE HAVE NO ISSUES WITH
WITH MOVING FORWARD TO TO BETTER
REFRIGERANTS THAT ARE.
A BETTER ON GWP --
BUT EVERYTHING HAS ITS TIME AND
PLACE AND I I KNOW THAT THEY
RESOURCES BOARD MUST TAKE IN THE
OVERALL RISK IN HEALTH.
AND THE ENVIRONMENT --
HOWEVER.
WHEN GLOBAL WARMING IS
CONSIDERED?
OUR THE DOUBTS OR SICKNESSES OF
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE OF WHAT
WHERE'S THE COMPARATIVE RISK.
AND SO WE GET CONCERNED GIVING A
ARE BE THE TOTAL AUTHORITY
UNFETTERED BY CODE BODIES IF
SOMEHOW THEY CONSTRAINED BY
CODE.
AND THEY WERE WORKING WITH THOSE
CO BODIES WE WOULD BE OKAY WITH
THE BILL WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE SAFETY OF OUR WORKERS.
THE SAFETY IN OCCUPANTS OF OUR
BUILDINGS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS INTO A
WILL BE BRIEF RESPECT HERE FOR
THE LATENESS AND FOR OTHER
WITNESS YOU LIKE I SEE A FOR THE
DOW CHEMICAL COMPANY
MANUFACTURES OF A NUMBER OF
PRODUCTS THAT ARE AFFECTED.
BY THE PHASE OUT PROPOSE AN SP
TEN THIRTEEN SPECIFICALLY FOAM
INSULATION YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT REFRIGERANTS.
BUT WHAT DOW CHEMICAL COMPANY
MAKES IS THE FOAM INSULATION
THAT YOU MIGHT BE FAMILIAR ITS
UBIQUITOUS THROUGHOUT THE
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL.
BUILDING AND IS AN ESSENTIAL
PRODUCT FOR MEETING OUR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT BY TAKING A
BIT OF THE SNAP REGULATION AND
DROPPING IT INTO CALIFORNIA
CODE.
AND ACTUALLY A BIT OF IT BECAUSE
WHAT YOU TOOK HERE WAS THE
DEADLINE TO PHASE OUT NOT THE
ENTIRETY OF THEIR REGULATION
WHICH ALLOWS FOR CONTINUED.
A RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
CONTINUED IN IT --
INVOLVEMENT BETWEEN THE
REGULATED PARTIES AND EPA TO
DEMONSTRATE THE FEASIBILITY OF
ALTERNATIVES AT EXACTLY WHAT THE
DOW CHEMICAL COMPANY HAS BEEN
DOING SINCE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE HAVE BEEN
INVESTING MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT
--
DEMONSTRATING TO EPA THE
FEASIBILITY OR NON FEASIBILITY
OF ALTERNATIVES.
WE HAVE YET TO FIND.
A SUITABLE REPLACEMENT FOR THAT
UBIQUITOUS INSULATION PRODUCT
THAT IS NECESSARY IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE NOT YET FOUND AND
INSULATION PRODUCT.
THAT MEANS CALIFORNIA'S TITLE
TWENTY FOUR STANDARDS THAT MEETS
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH FLAMMABILITY
STANDARDS.
SO YOU'VE HEARD WHAT YOU HEARD
FROM SO THE SUPPORTERS THAT WE
HAVE PRODUCTS THERE IN HOUSTON
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THAT MAY BE TRUE BUT THEY'RE NOT
IN USE IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD ASK YOU
TO TAKE SPECIAL --
MIND OF THAT WE NEED PRODUCTS
THAT NOT ONLY MEET THE SNAP
REGULATION TIMELINES THAT MEET
OUR UNIQUE CALIFORNIA.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY STANDARDS.
AND OUR FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS
SO WE A WE DO WANT TO WORK WITH
A SENATOR AND WE DO SEE THAT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS HERE ARE AN
ATTEMPT.
TO PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
THE AIRPORT --
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CLEAR ON WHAT THE
FLEXIBILITY BASED ON WHAT.
TITLE TWENTY FOUR STANDARDS
FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS THE TYPES
OF CONSIDERATIONS THAT EPA WILL
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE TODAY TO
DECIDE WHETHER THEY'RE IN FACT
IS A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE.
SO AGAIN BUT WE WE DO OPPOSE
THEM UNLESS I'M IN A POSITION
BUT WE DO WANT CONTENT OR FOR
THE SENATE AND THE STAFF ON
FINDING A SOLUTION
THANK YOU ARE I THINK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN --
JUST BRIEFLY.
THAT'S BECAUSE I AS I STATED
THAT EACH SIDE HAS THREE MAIN
WITNESSES.
ALLOW YOU --
GO A BRIEF PERIOD TIME TO MAKE A
CASE.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE --
THE COMMITTEE'S RULES BY SIMPLY
SAYING --
KEVIN WASHINGTON WITH ILLINOIS
TOOL WORKS --
WE'VE REGISTERED A LATER IT OUT
IT OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED AND
I IN THE INTEREST OF TIME IN THE
COMMITTEE'S RULES --
WHILE WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIR UPS USE ME WITH
THE OUT BILL AUTHORED A IN THE
PAST WE LOOK FORWARD.
A TO CONTINUE TO DO SO LOOKING
FOR AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO MOVE FROM OPPOSITION TO
NEUTRAL --
AND HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
HELP US FACILITATE THAT ACTION
BUT CURRENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF OUR KAMALA AND MEXICAN
FLOOR.
AND WERE OPPOSE THE BILLS WELL
BECAUSE IT.
ELIMINATES OUR EXAMS THE BOARD
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE PROCESS IS DESIGNED TO
EXAMINE THESE VERY ISSUES AND
THAT WE'RE JUST GOING.
TO SAY GO AHEAD AND DO IT WITHIN
YOUR TO THANK YOU.
AND APRICOT FILTHY WITH APEX
GROUP -- ON
BEHALF OF LENNOX INTERNATIONAL
WHERE OPPOSE THEM AS AMENDED
PRIMARILY FOR SAFETY CONCERNS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MS REYES.
THE ONE THING THAT I DID HEAR
THAT -- THAT
I HOPE YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION ON IS THE
SAFETY OF THE EMPLOYEES.
I HEARD THAT FROM AT LEAST TWO
OF THE OPPOSITION --
AND I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE THAT
CONTINUED DISCUSSION THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THE MANAGEMENT THE FOSTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I I
HAVE.
A FEW QUESTIONS HERE --
FOR ONE FOR THE AUTHOR COUPLE
FOR THE AUTHOR SO.
APOLOGIZE I WAS OUT OF THE ROOM
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR FROM HERE
BUT DISCARD CURRENTLY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO TIM TO MAKE
REGULATIONS FOR THIS BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT THE CARD IS ALREADY IN THE
PROCESS OF MAKING THEIR OWN
THEIR OWN RULES ON THAT.
YES CARVE ALREADY HAS THE
JURISDICTION TO DO SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS CREATE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM A GREAT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME LINES.
PUT THOSE IN STATUTES SO THAT WE
CAN ALLOW FOR THE TRANSITION OF
OF THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
ALSO ALLOW THE FLEXIBILITY. FOR
CARD IF EPA DOES A TRANSITION TO
WORK OR APPROVED NEW TECHNOLOGY
THAT THOSE ARE ADOPTED AS WELL
SO TRYING TO CREATE THE FLEXIBLY
THAT WE NEED.
WHAT THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM LIKE
RESOURCE THAT'S ME SUCCESSFULLY
HAVE DONE WITH THE METHANE
REDUCTION?
UP PIECE OF THAT WE SUPPORTED A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. OH OKAY SO
WITH THAT BEING SAID DOES THIS
SO AS WE'VE HEARD SOME TESTIMONY
ON DOES THE CIRCUMVENT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
[inaudible]
AND ALLEVIATE THE CONFERENCE OF
ANALYSIS JUSTIFICATION REQUIRED
BY THE ACT AND ALL THAT TIPS TO
SAY THAT.
WE'VE GOT SO MANY OTHER PIECES
OF THE PUZZLE HERE TITLE TWENTY
FOUR THE FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS
OF SAFETY RAGS.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
NO ONE CAN USE THIS.
THESE THESE PRODUCTS AT THIS
POINT EVEN IF THE STANDARDS WERE
THERE TODAY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT.
IS THAT THEY'RE NOT APPROVING A
PRIEST IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH THIS KEVIN MASTER THE
ASSOCIATIONAL APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS OF SANTORUM WERE
WERE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL NOW
AND IT IT.
CARP DOES HAVE THE AUTHORITY BUT
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GONNA DO.
AND SO THERE'S SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY RIGHT NOW WITH COURT
CASES IN EPA AND CANADA GOLLY.
THAT THIS BILL.
DOES TO PROVIDE THE CERTAINTY SO
YOU HAVE YOU KNOW NOW WE KNOW
NOW THE DATES THAT WE NEED TO
HIT.
AND AND CARP HAS THE FLEXIBILITY
SO WE WE HAVE A CHARGE SIZE
ISSUE THAT NO WE NEED TO GO
AFTER WITH A HUNDRED FIFTY GRAMS
AND SO THIS FLEXIBILITY DOES
RIGHT YOU YOU WE HAD A
CONVERSATION EARLIER LAST WEEK
ABOUT THIS VERY ISSUE AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GOING OFF.
OPPOSITION I'M I'M FRANKLY.
SHOCKED AT THE SUPPORT.
OF BECAUSE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN MY
OFFICE BUT WE'RE ONLY ADDRESSING
HALF THE ISSUE HERE --
AS WAS STATED WE PRIOR TO THIS
SENATE MEETINGS THAT I'VE HAD.
IF THIS STANDARD WERE ADOPTED
AND AND IF YOU'RE INDUSTRY HAD
GONE TO THESE PRODUCTS TO MEET
FOR EXAMPLE TO DO WHAT THE AB
ISOBUTANE.
YOU WOULD BE ABLE SOUND TODAY.
YOU HAVE WAREHOUSES FULL OF YET
FOR COMPLETELY FOLLOW THE
BELIEVER HERE AND WELL SO THAT'S
THAT'S A BIT OF A PROBLEM
BECAUSE THERE BE PEOPLE TODAY.
THAT FRANKLY WHO WENT TO THE
STANDARD CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
LEVINE REFRIGERATOR.
AND THERE'S ALSO PEOPLE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YEAH I'M
GONNA GO BACK TO TO ASK OTHER
TRAUMA FROM CARRIER AND I I I
WELCOME ANYONE TO TO ANSWER THIS
I ALSO LIKE TO ASK THE SHEET
METAL CONTRACTORS A QUESTION AS
WELL IT WITH THE CHURCH
INDULGENCE IF YOU.
DON'T MIND --
BECAUSE I IF THERE'S THERE'S TO
WE HAVE COMPETING INTERESTS AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IN THIS
STATE AND OBVIOUSLY WE WANT THE
THE THE CLEANEST AIR THE SAFEST
PRODUCTS THAT.
THE LOWEST COSTS ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN TRY TO ACHIEVE SEEMS
TO ME THAT WERE IN A POSITION
RIGHT NOW WHERE ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE HAVE A BREAKING RANKS AND WE
HAVE.
A HUGE PART OF THE INDUSTRY THAT
IS NOT ABLE TO AND TO MEET THESE
GUIDELINES AND I'M VERY
CONCERNED WITH THAT MISSED HER I
JUST WANT.
TO JUST CLARIFY THAT THEIR ART
CHILLERS CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW
WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
OPERATING IN THE U. S..
I I'M SURE THERE ARE BUT WHAT
ABOUT ISSUES LIKE.
YOU KNOW THESE THESE THESE
MANDATES COME DOWN AND NOW WE'VE
GOT PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE OTHERS
KNOW BACKWARDS COMPATABILITY
HERE THAT'S NO WAY TO REPAIR THE
SEE THESE THESE OF THE BEAST
BEAS CHILLERS THESE LARGE AC
UNITS THE H. BACK SYSTEMS OF OUR
HEARD ABOUT IT.
I MEAN THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT I THINK FRANKLY IN THIS
BILL KIND OF YOU KNOW KIND OF
SIDE STEPS I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT A SO --
IT IS MIX OF THEY ARE MAKE YOU
WOULD MIND I'M ASK THEM THAT
WITH CHAIRS DOSE AGAIN I'M WATER
THE RELEVANT CODES AND STANDARDS
THAT HAVE TO BE ACHIEVED BEFORE
YOU CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH
REPLACEMENTS WHAT ARE WE MISSING
THEIR THESE YOU MENTIONED IT.
EARLIER ON YEAH I THINK FIRST
AND FOREMOST WE HAVE TO GET THE
THE UNIFORM A CANTICLE CODE IN
PLACE TO ALLOW FOR A TWO WELLS
RICHARD OR THE MILDLY FINAL
REFRIGERANTS.
WHICH WHICH IS A BIG PART OF
THIS NOT NOW THERE MAY BE SOME
FOLKS OUT THERE WHO HAVE WITH
YOU KNOW A OF A B..
TO WHICH IT IS HIGHER TOXICITY
BUT BUT LOWER FLAMMABILITY ERRED
IN ALONG THOSE LINES YOU SEE SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OPTIONS THAT
ARE COMING OUT THEN YOU HAVE
SOME SOME GLIDES WITCHER --
KIND OF BLAND'S MEN AND IN OUR
PERSPECTIVE IT AS CARRIER WE
DON'T THINK THAT YOU KNOW GOING
THAT BLENDED OR OUTGOING EARLY
IS GOING TO GET TO THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE GOAL BASED ARM
MALI.
AND THAT THAT EXTRA TIME COULD
BE USED FOR FOR RECYCLING
RECOVERY OF EXISTING REFERRED
ANGELES HAS A LIKE 9% ACCORDING
TO AIR BEES.
NOW SAYS.
IT'S NOT THAT WERE UNSUPPORTIVE
OF GOING THE LOW GWP PATHWAY
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
WE'RE WE'RE A HAD HAD.
THE ENGINEERING STAFF AND AND
COMPLIANCE STAFF FLYING BACK AND
FORTH TO TO WORK ON THE COULD
ALL YOU GREEN.
AND AND ALL THOSE NEGOTIATED
POLICIES BUT WE HAVE YOU KNOW IF
YOU LOOK AT THE SNAP RULE IT IT
FOR CHILLERS IT SAYS TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND THE
JUSTIFICATION IS. TOO LOUD
RELEVANT CODES AND STANDARDS TO
GET A PLACE THAT INCLUDES THE
FIRE CODES.
THE FIRE CODES IT IF IF YOU'RE
MOVING TOWARDS A A PROPANE OR OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT FOR AND THIS
ISN'T TALKING.
NOTE THAT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
FIFTY GRAMS A HUNDRED FIFTY
GRAMS AN INTERPRETER AT WORK
WERE TALKING POUNDS OR TONS.
IF IT'S A MUCH GREATER QUANTITY
IN THESE BUILDINGS.
YEAH I I I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
THINK THE RECYCLING PIECE OF
THIS SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE MOVING TO THE RECYCLE
AND REUSE WARY DO AN AUTOMOTIVE
FIGHT COME FROM THAT WORLD AND
WE'VE BEEN IT THERE FOR YEARS --
IT'S REQUIREMENT --
IS NOW THAT THE THE SHEET METAL
WAS THAT YOU CAN'T TO SET THINGS
RIGHT I'M CITING CATCH YOUR NAME
I THOUGHT I'D MIX NAY BUT NEVER
GROUP CHRIS WATER CHRIS WALKER
OKAY THINKS CHRIS APPRECIATED --
MISTER WALKER SO.
KIND OF A GUY CAN TO THAT WAS
WHAT SAFETY STANDARDS THAT'S
JUST THE TALK CITY TOXIC CITY
TOXICITY OR FLAMMABILITY NEED TO
BE MET.
OUGHT TO ENSURE ANY REPLACE SOME
PRODUCTS ARE SAFE FOR THE
INSTALLERS AND TECHNICIANS --
FOR YOU KNOW CURRENT PER
POTENTIAL FUTURE YOU MENTIONED
SAFETY UP ANOTHER ANOTHER --
COMMITTEE MEMBER MENTIONED
SAFETY HAVING SOME EXPERTISE OR
SOME EXPERIENCE IN THIS WORLD I
I CAN TELL YOU THAT YOU KNOW
THIS ISN'T.
OUR TWELVE ARE ONE THIRTY FOUR A
IN YOUR CAR AND THEY JUST MIX
AND NEXT MESS UP YOUR
COMPRESSOR.
THIS IS FAR MANY MAGNITUDES
ABOVE THAT SO WE GAVE AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS NATIONWIDE MANY
YEARS TO PHASE THAT BOTH
PRODUCTS AND AND THE CONSUMER
MANY YEARS FOR REPLACEMENTS AND
FOR OUR TWELVE IN ITS ETRE.
A BEFORE WE YOU KNOW COMPLETELY
PUSHED IN PRICE AT THE MARKET
THIS IS A MUCH BIGGER SYSTEM
THAT WHAT'S IN YOUR AUTOMOBILE
AND ULTIMATELY THESE BUILDINGS
ARE REPLACED EVERY YEAR LIKE.
THE OUR TOUR FOR YEARS OR SIX
YEARS LIKE A CAR SO CAN YOU
TOUCH ON THAT THAT --
SURE TOXICITY EARLY CAN WE CAN
WE HAVE I MEAN WHAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE USING HYDRA
FLUOROCARBONS WHICH ARE NOT
PREFERABLE GIVEN THE GWP THAT
LOCAL WORKING POTENTIAL OF THESE
GASES.
ARE THE SAFEST OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW ANYTHING THAT WE GO --
IS GOING TO GO DOWN THE THAT
THAT THE PATH OF MORE TOXIC OR
MORE FLAMMABLE AND EVERYTHING'S
A TRADE OFF.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW WE'RE
GONNA HANDLE THESE THINGS IT'S A
VERY DELIBERATIVE PROCESS WITH
INDUSTRY WITH MANUFACTURERS
CHEMICAL COMPANIES.
ARE LABOR IT CETERA IN HOW ARE
WE GONNA WRAP OURSELVES WHAT CAN
A CODES NEED TO BE ADOPTED TO
HANDLE IF MORE FLAMMABLE
SUBSTANCE FOR EXAMPLE OR FOR
GOING TO BE DEALING WITH A MORE
TOXIC SUBSTANCE.
WHAT ARE THE CODES I HAVE TO GO
AROUND THAT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
IT'S A VERY COMPETITIVE
ATMOSPHERE --
IN IN IN THE INDUSTRY ARE
DIFFERENT COMPANIES ARE ARE
TRYING TO USE THE PROCESS TO GET
AHEAD OF OTHERS WE JUST
INSTALLED PROBE THAT THE
EQUIPMENT WE MAINTAIN THE
EQUIPMENT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE GET THERE WE GET THERE
SAFELY -- WE
DO YOU THINK THAT THAT CAN
HAPPEN --
AND WE'RE WE'RE NOT.
OBJECTING TO TIMELINES BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CODE
BODIES AREN'T BEING STEPPED
OVER.
AND DISREGARDED WE NEED THOSE
COLORED BODIES TO BE LOCK STEP
WITH WHATEVER THEY ARE BE IS
DOING CURRENTLY THE BILL DOES
NOT ALLOW THAT IT ALLOWS THEY
ARE BE. TO CIRCUMVENT THE CODE
BODIES.
RIGHT AND THERE WAS A REASON WHY
HAD YOU GO SECOND --
AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE HEARD FROM
A MANUFACTURER'S STANDPOINT --
I'M TECHNOLOGY OR MANUFACTURING
GNOSTIC ON THIS BUT THEN IT
COMES DOWN TO BECAUSE THEY CAN
THEY'RE GONNA WIN OR LOSE THAT
BATTLE BUT THEN IT COMES DOWN TO
THE ACTUAL YOU KNOW BOOTS ON THE
GROUND AND THESE ARE FOLKS THAT.
THAT WITH ALL RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR THAT THAT ARE ACTUALLY
DOING THIS WORK AND THERE'S A
LOT OF AREAS HERE THAT I HEAR
FROM -- MY
CONSTITUENTS AND FROM THE H.
BACK INSTALLERS JUST.
TODAY --
PARTICULARLY AND I I WANNA I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
UNDERSTAND SOMETHING HERE IF YOU
HAVE TO REPLACE OR REPAIR UNITS
YOU COULD BE IN A SITUATION THIS
AUGUST.
IN CALIFORNIA WITH OUR HEAT
WHERE YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO DO
IT DEPENDING WHAT CARD DOESN'T
HOW FAST THEY MOVE I'M NOT THIS
AUGUST BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING.
THESE ARE THE SITUATIONS THAT WE
FIND OURSELVES IN WERE WERE
GETTING AHEAD OF THE TECHNOLOGY
OR GETTING AHEAD OF THE RAGS
BECAUSE WE CAN'T IGNORE THE
REGULATORY THE SAFETY --
AND THAT AND SIDE OF THIS THING
AND I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT.
I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT TRYING TO DO HERE --
MISTER LARA BUT IT WOULD JUST
THERE'S ALMOST SAID WE HAVE THIS
THIS BIFURCATION AND I JUST
SIMPLY NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BUT I WOULD REALLY WANT.
THIS TO BE FIXED SOMEWHERE ALONG
THE LINE HERE BECAUSE I THINK
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GOING HEADLONG
INTO A TO AN ISSUE THAT I'VE
SEEN BEFORE SOMEONE IS.
USE THESE PRODUCTS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU ANY FURTHER.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I I JUST LIKE TO BRIEFLY --
ASCO EITHER HONEYWELL OR THE
ASSOCIATION TO RESPOND TO MR
COACHES.
INSURANCE SURE OUT WITH I THINK
ONE THING CLARIFY THIS BILL
ADDRESSES ONLY CHILLERS SNAP.
DEALS WITH THAT AND CHILLERS ARE
DIFFERENT AND UNLIKE YOUR HOME
AIR CONDITIONER I JUST HAD MINE
REPLACED TWO WEEKS AGO YOU DON'T
KNOW WHO'S COMING UP.
IT CHILLERS TYPICALLY EITHER
PLACED IN A CONTROLLED ACCESS
ROOM.
SERVICE BY PROFESSIONALS
TYPICALLY ALARMED VENTILATION
REQUIREMENTS WELL SPECIFIED
WORKPLACE THAT'S TODAY.
ALL THE LEADING KILLER MANY
FACTORS INCLUDING CARRIER HAS
MULTIPLE OPTIONS SO MUCH OF
PLAYABLE SOME WHICH ARE NOT --
THEY HAVE A PRODUCT CALLED ONE
TWO THREE THREE Z. DE WHICH
TRAIN CARRIER JOHNSON CONTROLS
DAIKIN AND OTHERS SELL TODAY
THAT IS NON FLAMMABLE I
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE USED IN.
OF CALIFORNIA JUST RECENTLY
THERE WAS A PRESS RELEASE WHERE
A TRAIN REPLACE THE FOR CHILLERS
IN THE CHANNEL WHICH IS THE
TYPICAL PANEL DOES UNDER THE AND
FROM THE UK FRANCE.
WHERE THEY WERE PLACED FOR LARGE
CHILLERS WITH BREEZY DE CHILLERS
TRAIN AND REDUCED --
THOSE CHILLERS IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN SO GIVING THEM TEN
YEARS TIME SEEMS TO YOUR POINT
YOU DON'T WANT TO MOVE TOO
QUICKLY BUT TENURE SEEMS.
THAT REASONABLY PROVED THERE
ABOUT FIFTEEN PEOPLE TODAY
OFFERING LOW GDP CHILLERS WITH
REGARD TO THE CODES THE OTHER
CODE BODIES HAVE ALREADY
ADDRESSED WITH NICOLE.
INDIRECT SYSTEMS WHICH ARE
CHILLERS.
A DIRECT ESTAMOS IN YOUR HOME
THE AIR CONDITIONER THE
REFRIGERANT COULD FLOW THROUGH
BUT INDIRECT SYSTEM ALL THAT
REFRIGERANT STAYS EITHER IN THAT
LOCKED MECHANICAL ROOM OR SO I
THINK IT IS A DIFFERENT
SITUATION.
IF I MAY MISTER WITH YOUR
SOLDIERS ARE BECAUSE IT WAS
DIRECTED AT ME --
IN RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION I
HAD I UNDERSTAND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CHILL BUT WE'RE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT YOUR EAR YOU YOU
WERE ABLE TO GO DOWN TO ONE
MANUFACTURER THAT'S NOT THE
ISSUE HERE.
THE ISSUE THAT I WAS TRYING TO
GET AT IS THE FACT THAT.
THERE ARE FOLKS FROM INDUSTRY
THAT ARE COMING TO US AND SAYING
THERE ISN'T THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
SAFETY CONCERNS HERE SO AYE I
DON'T THINK WE WE NEED TO GOING
TO BACK AND FORTH ALREADY STATED
MY POSITION.
BUT THAT DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
THE THE THE THOUSANDS OF
TECHNICIANS OUT THEIR THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET A HEAD OF FROM THE
SAFETY STANDPOINT I'VE TALKED TO
PEOPLE IN THE IN THE FIRE SAFETY
WE ARE PROGRAMS FIREFIGHTERS.
I'VE TALKED TO PEOPLE IN
BUILDING AND SAFETY IN CODES I
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT WE'VE GOT THE
CART BEFORE THE HORSE HERE BUT
I'VE.
I'VE SAID MY PIECE I APPRECIATE
INDOLENCE OF THE CHAIR AND MY
FELLOW MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SETTLER WAS
LIKE LOS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE THE THE CONVERSATION
AND ALSO JUST FOR THE RECORD
OPEN ALSO CARE ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF FOLKS.
ARE NOT TO MAKE AN ASSUMPTION
THAT DIDN'T BUT AGAIN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILLERS HERE
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
A TRACK SYSTEMS AND WILL YOU
HAVE A METHODICAL APPROACH WHEN
IT COMES TO BUILDING SAFETY AND
THAT PROCESS FITS OUR TIMELINES.
A IT WE JUST WANT TO CONFLATE
THE TWO ISSUES AND MAKE IT
DIFFERENT OF THE FACT IS THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS ALREADY EXIST.
AYE AND THE FACT THAT WE
ACTUALLY.
SAT UP THE TABLE AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH INDUSTRY AND
BROUGHT A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE SHOULDN'T SURPRISE YOU
HAVEN'T YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT MY
FIRST RODEO --
AND WE ACTUALLY LISTEN TO
INDUSTRY AND SO WE HAVE A BIG
SEGMENT OF THE INDUSTRY NOW
WHO'S IN SUPPORT.
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTOOD THAT THEY
NEED THE TIME GOING TO NEED THE
FLEXIBILITY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
OF THAT WHEN EPA RULES.
THAT E. R. R. UM.
RTP HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADOPT TO WHATEVER NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE BEING ADDRESSED
OR WHATEVER THEN THE DEADLINES
ARE TIMES ARE.
SO I MEAN I THINK WE'VE DONE OUR
DUE DILIGENCE IN TRYING TO
REALLY GET TO THE CRUX OF THE
ISSUE HERE BUT DON'T WANT TO
CONFLATE.
THE ISSUES BETWEEN A TRAP AND
ABOUT I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
START THE CONCERN AS A MODEL FOR
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM SECRETARY MOTIONS BEEN
MADE AND SECONDED [inaudible]
BROKE UP.
I DON'T THREE SB TEN THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR LOTT OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED IN REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE ROUTE
TUCCI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NO CHILD.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I'VE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ LENDERS NO RADIUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
SONA. THREE CLICKS CLEAR THE
BILL ITSELF THANK YOU SO MUCH
FROM.
NEXT WE HAVE --
CENTER ALLEN PRESENTING TWO
BILLS. SEVEN TWENTY AND S. B..
TEN FIFTEEN WELL THANK YOU
MEMBERS SOON TO PERSEVERE.
STAYING HERE NICE IN LATE
WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE.
MOVE THE BILL.
CAN HIT HER HEAD ON HER HEAD.
ACTUALLY LET'S CLARIFY WHICH
BILL OF WHICH WAS A. B. EYES BE
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TERMINOLOGY CASE AND ALRIGHT SO
MOTIONS BEEN MADE BY MS EGGMAN
AND SECOND BY MISS RATES OKAY
I'M HEARING BIPARTISAN SECOND
I'M HAPPY TO AND THERE.
IS TO GIVE MORE INFORMATION IF
PEOPLE HAVE QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT --
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENTING
WITNESSES FOR ARE YOU GOOD YES
WHAT WE SOW AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH --
WITH TEN STRANDS AND I'M A
NUMBER OF ENVIRONMENT IS A SWEET
CARING CAO HERE WHO I'M SURE
WOULD LIKE SICK UPWARDS
[inaudible]
GOOD EVENING.
I JUST A FEW WORDS --
TIME KAREN KAREN THE CEO OF TEN
STRONGEST FOR SPONSORING THE
BILL AND I MOST OF THE PROJECT
DIRECTOR.
OF CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
LITERACY INITIATIVE.
THAT'S A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP THAT INCLUDES
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
ON THE OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
THE ENVIRONMENT CAL RECYCLE --
WORK COLLECTIVELY FOCUSES ON
ESTABLISHING A SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR STUDENTS.
AND IN THE TIME THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS THERE'S MORE
MOMENTUM THAN EVER BEFORE THAN
THAN ANY AT ANY OTHER TIME THAT
WE'VE SEEN.
AND SO WITH S. B. SEVEN TWENTY
WOULD JUST LIKE TO KEEP THAT
MOMENTUM GOING BY STRENGTHENING
LEGISLATION --
GOING INTO TWENTY NINETEEN
NOTICE OF THE NEW GOVERNOR
SUPERINTENDENT.
SO SPECIFICALLY --
JUSTIN AND IN SUMMARY SB SEVEN
TWENTY INCLUDES CHANGES THAT
WILL.
DEEPEN EDUCATION RESOURCES
AGENCIES COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
PRINCIPLES AND CONCEPTS.
GIVE CLEAR DIRECTION TO THE NEW
STATE SUPERINTENDENT TO
FACILITATE BRINGING
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACIES TO
STUDENTS.
AND ENCOURAGED LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS TO BE MORE ACTIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY.
AND STRENGTH AND CAL RECYCLES
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT ABILITY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
EDUCATION RESOURCE AGENCIES.
WHENEVER YOUNG PEOPLE ARE BEING
EDUCATED ABOUT USING THE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRINCIPLES AND
CONCEPTS.
AND TO FACILITATE A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS FOR
REVISING THEM WHEN APPROPRIATE.
SO WE BELIEVE SB SEVEN TWENTY IS
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
BUILDING A SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE SPUR THE BILL THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND SUPPORT I WAS
ALSO ASKED TO EXTEND THE SUPPORT
OF A LOT OF ON CALIFORNIA LATINO
OUTDOORS AZUL.
AND THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY SUPPORT.
CHURN MEMBERS WE CAN OCCUR AGAIN
WITHOUT RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THINK.
ANY MARIN AMBIANCE HERE COULD
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
A FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MOTION MADE AND
SECONDED --
SENATOR ALLEN WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
SHE'D NEVER WENT SUPPORT AND
RESPECT THAT'S RIGHT VOTE --
BEFORE WE ASK FOR ROLL CALL
LIKE.
WILL ACCEPT ALL AMENDMENTS YES
YES YES ABSOLUTELY.
THEM I AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE
FORK ON THE BILL.
THE PARENT WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION ROCO.
I AM TWO SB SEVEN TWENTY BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ARE OUT SEARCHING AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN
[inaudible]
EGGMAN AYE.
FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
LET US NOT VOTING [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE AYE [inaudible]
IT. EIGHT ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
NEXT WE HAVE OUR S. B..
TEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS I I JUST ALSO WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO CLOSELY
WITH US ON THIS MEASURE AND I'M
HAPPY.
TO ACCEPT THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS DISCUSS ANALYSIS.
I'M ALSO COMMITTED TO WORK
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL.
MOVES FORWARD.
I S. B. TEN FIFTEEN ESTABLISHES
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
RESILIENCY PROGRAM AND FIND
WITHIN THAT WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO FIND
PROVEN PROJECTS AT A REGIONAL
LEVEL THAT WILL BE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO PROMOTE.
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND INCREASE
THE STATE'S ABILITY AND MITIGATE
ADAPTS TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WHILE ALSO.
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
THE THE DEBBIE SEE BE THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD AND
COASTAL CONSERVANCY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY FUNDING AND
IMPLEMENTING.
PROJECTS DESIGNED TO CAPTURE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS I WHILE
HELPING WITH COMMUNITIES NATURAL
RESOURCES --
DOT TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE OVER OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND SO BUILDING ON THE
SUCCESSFUL MODELS.
WITH THIS BILL WORK TRYING TO
SCALE UP THOSE TRIPS THOSE SORTS
OF EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT WE
BUILD A COORDINATED AND COHESIVE
STATEWIDE.
PROGRAM TO GUIDE EFFORTS TO
ENSURE A NATURAL RESOURCES ARE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS SEVERAL
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM WORKING AND
NATURAL LANDS BUT OUR APPROACH
ALLOWS GRANTING AGENCIES TO
TAILOR FUNDING TO RESILIENCY
PROGRAMS.
AND PROJECTS THAT MEET THE NEEDS
OF A GIVEN COMMUNITY OR REGION.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY
HERE THE BROAD RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES ALLOWED FOR IN THE
BILL AND ENSURE THAT EACH REGION
IN OUR STATE IN EACH COMMUNITY
WILL BE ABLE TO COMPETE FOR
FUNDS.
EITHER THROUGH THEIR LOCAL
CONSERVANCY OR IF THEY DON'T
HAVE ONE THROUGH THE THAT PCB.
ARE CONSERVANCY IS AS AS WE NOW
HAVE FIVE QUITE A BIT OF
EXPERIENCE BOTH ADDRESSING
ADAPTATION RESILIENCY AND
IMPORTANTLY WORKING EFFECTIVELY
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT LOCAL PRIORITIES SO.
IT'S OUR STRONG SENSE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T WAIT TO SET UP A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM FOCUSED ON
NATURAL RESOURCE ADAPTATION IN
THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE'VE
SEEN FIRES MUDSLIDES DROUGHTS
FLOODS EXTREME HEAT LEVELS.
ARE CONSERVANCY ISN'T OF THE CBO
WELL.
PLACE TO HELP TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND I CAN CONTINUE TO BE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE EVERY EFFECT
RIGHT AFTER I VOTE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
MOTIONS WERE MADE BY MS RIOTS
[inaudible]
SACRAMENTO STROUSTRUP.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OR TO ACHIEVE
MARK FENCE TO MAKE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB.
TEN FIFTEEN THE SENATE ALREADY
HAD ON THAT --
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HAVING REAL
IMPACTS ON OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
NOW IT CITED SOME OF THAT THE
RECENT DISASTERS THAT WE'VE SEEN
--
INCLUDING HER AROUND
TEMPERATURES AND MORE INTENSE
WILD FIRES.
AND SO WE REALLY DO NEED A
FUNDING PROJECTS THAT BILL
CLIMATE RESILIENCE FOR NATURAL
SYSTEMS ARE NATURAL RESOURCES.
ME TO PROTECT THESE RESOURCES
AND SYSTEM SO THAT THEY IN TURN
CAN PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
OR WE'VE BEEN WITNESSING THAT
THE OPPOSITE IS HAPPENING --
THANKS TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
NATURE CONSERVANCY SPONSORED
BILL BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
BY NOW CONGRESSMAN TED LIU SET
UP A PROGRAM AT THE COAST
CONSERVANCY TO DO THIS TYPE OF
WORK WE'VE FOUND THAT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL SO FAR IN THIS REALLY
BUILDS OFF OF THAT AND SCALES IT
OUT TO THE REST OF THE STATE.
I REALLY APPRECIATIVE CENTER
ALLEN'S THAT LEADERSHIP IN
APPROACH HERE IN RESPECTFULLY
URGE DRIVE OUT.
Q. AND A FOR THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT CERTAIN MEMBERS THE
SOLOMON SALAS POTTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FUND
THE CALIFORNIA BE SUPPLANT
COUNSEL'S SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE.
AND PENINSULA OPEN SPACE TRUST
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA TROUT.
IN SUPPORT OF ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
CONVEY THE SUPPORT OF THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND THINK.
GOOD EVENING ALAYNE OR TEASE ON
BEHALF OF BIG SUR LAND TRUST THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AND THE WILDLINGS CONSERVANCY
AND SUPPORT THINK YOU.
VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
A FOUR AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
XENA QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MS EGGMAN THEM MISSED
MCCARTY [inaudible]
AND THANK YOU.
SO.
I GUESS MY QUESTIONS ABOUT DO
YOU KNOW HOW MANY AREAS DON'T
HAVE STATE CONSERVANCY'S
[inaudible]
WELL WE NEED HOW.
I MEAN IT WELL BECAUSE YOU'RE
SAYING IT MIGHT SO MY AREA
DOESN'T HAVE A STATE CONSERVANCY
RIGHT SO THAT THAT MEANS AND IT
WOULD FOLLOW UNDER THAT VERY.
OF DIVERSITY RIGHT SO I GUESS
WHAT I'M ASKING IS HOW MANY
AREAS IN THE STATE DO NOT HAVE
CONSERVANCY.
AND THAT THE WC BE WILL BE DOING
THOSE PROGRAMS.
DO THEY HAVE ENOUGH FAMILIARITY
WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
SOME THINK MAYBE SOME ARE WAY UP
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
HAVE.
ONE I'M THINKING MY AREA THAT TO
MIX OF AG AND AND AND URBAN.
DOESN'T HAVE ONE SO THOSE ARE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT MEANS SO I'M
WONDERING IF THE AGENCY THAT
YOU'RE SIGNING THIS.
TOO HAS A CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
DO IT.
ARE THEY GONNA HAVE STAFF UP OR
THEY CAN HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND OF THE ME WORKING IN
COORDINATION WITH MY LOCALS.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION WHEN.
I SAY HOW MANY.
AREAS DON'T HAVE THEM.
AND THEN WHAT I MEAN WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN ABOUT CAPACITY FOR AN
AGENCY.
YET SO ARE CERTAINLY THEY THEY
WOULD BECAUSE OF THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT NOT ALL
THE STATE AND I COVERED BY IT
CONSERVANCY THEY WOULD DURING A
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THE STORY
I KNOW.
YOU MAY KNOW IT TALKS ABOUT THIS
IN ANNOUNCESON PAGE.
FIVE IWC BRT HOUSE APARTMENT
PLACE THAT AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTING
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE.
AUTHORED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
A GIRAFFE FUNDING.
AND I'LL ON ON SIMILAR TYPES OF
PROJECTS AND THAT WAS IT IS
GOING TO IT AND POPULAR OUR
NUMBER ONE UP EVENLY EXAMINE DO
NOTHING IDEA WE WE LOOKED IN AND
A LOT OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS AND
AND FOUND A REALLY.
MEAN IN.
DEEP DISCUSSIONS OVER THAT'S
RESOURCES OVER AT THE SENATE
SIDE IN.
FELT THAT THIS WAS THE BEST
PLACE TO YOU KNOW TO HANDLE
THOSE AREAS THAT WERE COVERED BY
THE CONSERVANCY'S.
BUT CERTAINLY IF YOU'VE GOT A
SUGGESTION OFFER DIFFERENT.
BEFORE FOR OR YOU KNOW ME KNOW
I'M DIFFERENT MODEL THAT I'M
SOMETHING ABOUT THE CAPACITY OF
THE OF THE OF THE AGENCY YEAH
YOU'RE YOU'RE WE'RE CITING IT A
WHOLE BUNCH OF NEW THINGS.
THAT DIFF DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
WILL BE DEPENDENT UPON THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE AREA AND ABLE
TO DO THE MEDICATION BEYOND THE
USE THE MONEY [inaudible]
I DON'T.
HERE -- IF I
IF I MAY JUMP IN HERE FOR JUST A
MINUTE WHAT WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD OVER
THE YEARS IS THROUGH VARIOUS
BOND MEASURES AND THROUGH
VARIOUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND THEY'VE ADEQUATELY
STAFFED UP THEY DO WORK I'M
RANGING FROM THE DESERT ALL THE
WAYS YOU POINT OUT ALL THE WAY
UP TO THEN ORGAN BORDER --
AND HAVE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
DIFFERENT STAFF EXPERTISE TO
MEET THOSE DIFFERENT RESOURCES
TYPES SO WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
FORESTLANDS UP UP NEAR THE CLAIM
ETHERIA OR THEIR ITS
AGRICULTURAL LANDS BABY NEAR
WHERE YOUR DISTRICT LIES OR
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
PROTECTION OUT IN THAT THE
DESERT DOWN NEAR THE ARIZONA
BORDER THAT THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD HAS
HISTORICALLY AND CONTINUES TO
FUND PROJECTS --
AT THE GROUND LEVEL FROM ACROSS
THOSE DIFFERENT AND RESOURCES
TYPES AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE WE
WORKING WITH THE CENTER FELT
LIKE THEY WOULD BE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE PLACE TO PUT THIS
TYPE OF PROGRAM.
I'M HERE TODAY.
NOT THAT I KNOW.
ALRIGHT MR MCCARTY THEN MS LIVE
ON THANK YOU SENATOR I AM VERY
MUCH OPEN.
TO WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH AND FAMILIAR WITH THE
WILDLIFECONSERVATION BOARD WE
HAVE A NEW PROGRAM FOR THIS
AREA.
BEAUTIFUL AMERICAN WERE
CONSERVANCY.
ISN'T IS NOW HAS A PROGRAM.
UNDER THE BOARD AND POTENTIALLY
THEY COULD BE PART OF THESE
EFFORTS FINA RELATES A CLIMATE
RESILIENCY I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FROM IN THIS IT WOULD NOT LEAD
TO THE PROGRAM WHICH IS
PRIORITIES AND FUNDING AND SO
FORTH.
SO I KNOW IT IN LA YOU HAVE OR
THIS IN DOING THAT URBAN
FORESTRY THAT TREAT PEOPLE
THOUSAND UP.
YET SO HERE IN SACRAMENTO HAVE
ONE CALLED THE SACRAMENTO THREE
FOUND.
OKAY BEEN AROUND FOR DECADES.
AND SO THEY HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
RESOURCES THROUGH THE CALPERS
URBAN COMMUNITY FORESTRY
PROGRAM.
AND QUESTION THEY HAD FOR ME
LEVEL LETTER OPPOSITION.
THEY HAD NONE OF THIS IS A BILL
OF COURSE WE WANT THE FIGHT BUT
THE FUN PIECE.
IS IS THAT WE SHOULD BE DO
HAVEN'T LIBERAL POSITION NO THEY
DO NOT ONLY GOT ROCKET THEY
DON'T NEED AND SO THEY DON'T
HAVE A LETTER OUT THIS I GOT
THEY ASKED ME AS A REPRESENT IT
TOO YEAH.
DID YOU KNOW THEY LIKE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WITH
THIS ONE I KNOW HOW WILL THIS ON
HOW WILL THIS IMPACT EXISTING.
PRIORITY PROGRAMS LIKE THE CAL
FIRE.
URBAN AND COMMUNITY FORESTRY
PROGRAM.
THERE FUNDING RIGHT NOW IN THE
GDR AT VIA AND SO WOULD THIS BE
COMPETITION OR HOW THAT ALL
PLAYS OUT DOESN'T IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S A SEPARATE.
IT CAN STAND ALONE AREA OF THE
GIRAFFE NEW.
THAT WOULD FOCUS ON RESILIENCY
NATURISTS OURSELVES IN AND
THERE'D BE THERE'D THERE WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE FINANCE FOR FOR
THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS SO
YOU'RE DOING HERE IS THERE'S
LIKE WE SEEN QUITE A FEW BILLS
WHICH IS TO CREATE.
A UP PROGRAM WHICH SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE UNDER GIGI ARE HALF AND
THEN.
IN THE ANNUAL PROCESS WE WOULD
HAVE TO ALLOCATE.
MONIES ACCORDING EFFECTIVELY VIA
[inaudible]
NO.
FAIR ENOUGH THANK YOU KNOW.
MUSLIM UP TO M. MAKE COMMENTS
AND I GUESS QUESTIONS WERE ALONG
THAT I THINK THIS MIRRORS AND
SOMETHING THAT THE SENATE RATE
YOUR F. PROPOSAL IN SOME WAYS
AND AS A DISTRICT THAT'S BEEN.
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY WILDFIRES
AYE RIGHT YOU ONLY HAVE A POT
THAT SO BIG BUT IF IT'S GONNA
TAKE AWAY --
FROM CAL FIRE HEALTHY FOREST
FIRE PREVENTION --
AREAS --
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME THROUGH
OUR COMMITTEE THAT WE'VE ALSO
LET OUT I JUST I WANTED TO KNOW
HOW THAT WAS GONNA INTERFACE I
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE COMMON IS
WELL.
PROP SIXTY CAN BACK FILL BACK AT
SOME POINT.
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY AT SOME
POINT THE GT R. F. FUNDS STOP
AND SO I THINK BACK TO WHAT WAS
BEING SAID WHAT IS THE PRIORITY
HOW DO WE UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THIS -- AND
CLEARLY YOU KNOW THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BOAT.
YOU KNOW HOW ARE YOU THINKING
ABOUT THE PRIORITY NOW THESE ARE
ULTIMATELY THESE ARE BUDGET
NEGOTIATION DECISIONS AND IT
WILL BE A PRESUMABLY GATHERED
CERTAIN POOR IF IF IT PASSES WE
GET A CERTAIN PORTION OF THE G.
GIRAFFE ALLOCATION AND AND BUT
BUT WE ALL KNOW THERE'S GONNA
BE.
A LOT OF STRONG SUPPORT. FOR FOR
FIRE RESULT THE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DESCRIBING BECAUSE
OF ALL THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
HAD IN AND BECAUSE OF HOW MANY
MEMBERS OF AN IMPACT SO.
YOU KNOW THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT
INTENDED TO MEAN AND I'D I'D DIE
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WILL THAT
WILL.
BE IT WILL --
YOU KNOW TAKE AWAY THOSE KINDS
OF PROGRAMS BECAUSE THERE'S
THEY'RE THEY'RE SO IMPORTANT AND
THEY'RE SO THEY'RE SO POPULAR
HERE IN THIS BUILDING BUT
ULTIMATELY.
AND THIS IS NEEDED TO THE EXTENT
TO WHICH IS FUND IT WILL BE THE
PRODUCT OF OUR BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS OVER THE GIRAFFE.
BUT AND I KNOW THAT THIS WILL BE
NEGOTIATION I GUESS THAT THE S.
SOMEONE WHO KEEPS HEARING M..
ALTHOUGH WONDERFUL IDEAS THAT
YOU'RE ASKING DO YOU YOU KNOW I
JUST HAVE TO RAISE THE QUESTION
WHO AM I WISHED.
THERE WAS MORE THERE TO DO MORE
BUT THAT'S YOU KNOW REALLY CAN'T
BE OUR ONLY SOURCE OF THINKING
ABOUT THESE THINGS BUT I AM I DO
YOU KNOW WHERE YOU'RE TRYING TO
GO ON A SUPPORT THAT.
WE THINK YOU.
BY THE WAY I MEAN THE
CONSERVANCY'S IN YOUR AREA WILL
CERTAINLY BE ABLE TO BENEFIT AND
THERE WILL BE A FOLLOW ON IMPACT
ON ON ON FIRE IS ONTO TO
ASSOCIATE WITH THIS PROJECT.
NO DOUBT THAT THE CONSERVANCY'S
IN THAT INTEREST OF OUR AREA
WILL -- ALSO
BENEFIT FOR THIS I THINK THAT
WHAT WE DEAL WITH AS LEGISLATORS
ARE --
COMPETING.
AND COMPELLING INTEREST RATE TO
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE I THINK
TRYING TO GET AT ALRIGHT ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THE COMMITTEE.
SIR I JUST WANTED TO REINFORCE
WHAT I THINK A IT'S MCCARTY AND
MUSLIM ON ALSO.
HAVE F. TOUCHED UPON WHICH IS
THE CONCERN ABOUT [inaudible]
DUPLICATION --
OR CONSOLIDATION.
THESE WONDERFUL PROGRAMS THAT
OTHER AID AGENCIES HAVE BEEN --
ADMINISTERING A BABY YOU'RE
YOU'RE MAKING A CLEAR THAT YOUR
INTENT AT LEAST THIS IS. FOR
THIS TO NOT SUPPLANT ANY OTHER
EFFORTS BOTH TO BE AND AND IN
ADDITION --
TO AND TO COMPETE.
FOR A THE ADVANTAGES ARE FUNDS.
THAT'S RIGHT I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
THAT YOU DRAFT IS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY --
BUT BUT THE DESERVE THESE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP ARE ARE ARE VITALLY IMPORTANT
THEY'RE POPULAR IN AND NOW I'M I
AND I KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE A
LOT OF I SUPPORT FOR FOR FINING
THEM ROBUSTLY.
I'M THIS IS JUST AT THE BENEFIT
OF BUT THAT BUT THE ISSUES THAT
ARE RAISED BY THIS BILL I THINK
THAT DESERVE ADDRESSING AS WELL
[inaudible]
I'VE.
AND AND WE'RE HOPING FOR FOR OF
A PROGRAM TO HAVE IN PLACE FOR
TO START WITH WITH SOME WITH
SOME FUNDING AND AND AND SOME
[inaudible]
SOME PROGRAMMING --
BUT BUT THERE'S ABSOLUTE NO
INTENTA TO DERAIL ANY VISA
PROGRAMS OKAY ABSOLUTELY.
ALRIGHT SEEING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
WHAT PROJECT THE DISCUSSION
CERTAINLY WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH THE MEMBERS AND AND YOU
KNOW IF IF IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS%
ABOUT THE EXTENT TO WHICH DEBBIE
SEABEES ABLE TO OPT TO HANDLE?
ALSO IS A VERY TO THE STATE
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT AND AND AND
WORK ON CAPACITY BUILDING --
BUT BUT I DO THINK IT THIS IS
ULTIMATELY A AND A SOLVE THAT
ONE LITTLE PIECE OF THE BRIDE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE.
WITH REGARDS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES RESILIENCY AND THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD SO I
ASK YOU.
TO JOIN.
APPARENTLY THE TROUT.
AND THAT IT CENTER HANNAH BETH
JACKSON IS THERE JEFF STONE IN
[inaudible]
SUPPORTING [inaudible]
SPELL [inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
MOTION'S BEEN MADE AND SECONDED.
ACCOMPLICE ITEM FOUR SP TEN
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR ALLEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTE TO CHIEF AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA I CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA [inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ.
MELINDA SNOW RAYOS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE FIGURES [inaudible]
YOU.
THEY'RE JUST REALISTIC.
I WAS ALWAYS ACCOUNT.
WHAT ABOUT JOHN EIGHT ONE THE
BILL IS OUT WE WILL NOW ALLOW
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO ANY
PREVIOUS?
THE FISCAL OKAY LEFT THE CALL ON
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE SP ADULTS THREE HOURS TO
BUILD.
ITEM ONE SB SIXTY FOUR CURRENT
VOTERS FIVE TO ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA.
NO ACOSTA NO CHAU.
CHAU AYE.
MELENDEZ BELINDA'S NO
[inaudible] SEVEN THREE FELLOWS
OUT.
ITEM TWO S. B..
SEVEN TWENTY CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBER MCCARTY.
I MCCARTY AYE [inaudible] NINE
ZERO WELL.
GOING BACK TO ITEM ONE SB SIXTY
FOR THE FINAL [inaudible]
MOMENTS.
BUT ON THE YEAH FACT ITEM ONE SB
SIXTY FOR THE FINAL COUNT WAS.
SIX TO THREE AND THEN WE JUST
FINISHED ITEM TO S. B..
SEVEN TWENTY FINAL CO.
IS.
NINE ZERO ITEM THREE SB TEN
THIRTEEN LARA THE CURRENT VOTE
IS SIXTY THREE WITH THE
TRAVELING I ABSENT MEMBER
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE [inaudible] SEVEN
THREE BUT THAT ON THAT NUMBER
TWO SEVEN TWENTY THAT I GET TO
VOTE ON THAT.
ONE YES VOTED AYE ON THAT.
ONE THE MARKET THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT BY ME.
WE'RE OKAY RETURN.
OKAY OF THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
YEAH